Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So Leute, ich hab nichts spezielles vor.
Ich hab jetzt nur noch eineinhalb Stunden Zeit, bevor ich auf muss.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, komm.
Mach's einfach streamen.
Und gucken wir mal, ob's irgendwas gibt, was wir machen können.
So, ich mach mal meine Vm an, da ich nix vergess.
Weiß ja nie.
Ich geh dann auf, ja.
Naja, ich muss morgen wieder arbeiten gehen.
Wofür brauchst du Keycloak?
Ich weiß so grob, was Keycloak ist.
Das ist irgend so ein Autodifizierungszeug.
Oh, da gab's dort Riesendiskussionen auf GitHub, hab ich gesehen.
Es gibt jetzt ein paar Projekte auf GitHub, die haben ihren Master Branch umbenannt in Main.
Und da gibt's Riesendiskussionen.
Das ist so ein Thema, wo ich bedenke, ey, vielleicht hat's nen Funken Sinn, das zu machen.
Aber in Anbetracht der Tatsache, was es für einen Aufwand verursacht, weiß ich nicht, ob das im Verhältnis steht.
Naja, sollen sie machen.
Ich kann jedes Projekt entscheiden, wie sie wollen.
Weiß ich, ob ich die ersten drei Fragen schon hatte?
Hab ich das schon mal antwortet, das letzte Mal?
Weiß nicht, wenn nicht, kann ich's nochmal machen, weil das ist keine schlechte Frage.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Hab ich mir auch schon gedacht, wie sieht's mit dem Masterstudiengang aus, ja?
Also, gar so einfach ist es nicht.
Aber es soll jedes Projekt machen, wie sie wollen.
Ist mir eigentlich wurscht.
Ist mir ehrlich gesagt egal.
Also ich werde auf der Arbeit unsere Gitbranche nicht umbenennen, weil da müsste ich alle Skripte, alle Hooks, alle Pipeler, alles ändern.
Da hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Weil so einfach mit Search and Replays ist es nicht getan.
Sobald es wieder genug Low-Brain-Leute gibt, die erst wieder drei Monate brauchen, bis sie was gecheckt haben.
Sobald es zu Daily-Streams übergeht, wenn sich das ergibt, so wie aktuell, dann ich stream so, wie es passt.
Ich stream so, wie es passt.
Die Blende hab ich ja nach wie vor nicht.
Hast du die Corona-Warn-App schon auf dem Staubsauger installiert?
Nee, auf dem Staubsauger läuft leider nur Android 5.
Das ist zu niedrig.
Boah, heute ist ja Twitter wieder explodiert, Leute.
Mit der Corona-App.
Die Leute sind vollkommen eskalierend gewesen.
Vor allem, ich finde das komplett in bescheu...
Also komplett unrational sinnlosen Gründen.
Das haben sich alle auf Twitter irgendwie am Datenschutz von der Corona-App hochgezogen.
Also eine Sache muss man ihnen ja mal echt zugute halten.
Sie versuchen es diesmal. Sie versuchen es.
Nach dem ersten Anlauf mit der Corona-App, die komplett für den Arsch war,
den das CCC in ihrem Bericht ja komplett auseinandergenommen haben,
diese Corona-App vom Robert Koch-Institut, das haben die komplett auseinandergenommen.
Der zweite Versuch jetzt, sie geben sich wirklich Mühe.
Ich mein, komm mal.
Also so anonym, wie es irgendwie geht.
Es ist Open Source auf GitHub.
Es gibt demnächst sogar Daily-Builds.
Also geben sie sich wirklich Mühe.
Warum ich mir die Corona-App erst mal nicht installieren würde, installiere, ist in zwei Gründen.
Erstens, ich habe eh 24-7 Homeoffice quasi aktuell.
Da komme ich eh kaum unter Leute.
Und zweitens, ich habe ein iPhone 6, was ich unterwegs dabei habe.
Darauf läuft das Ganze leider nicht.
Und der dritte Punkt ist, dass ich absolut kein Vertrauen in die Fähigkeiten
aus der Kombination Bundesregierung, Telekom, SAP habe, was Security-Geschichten angeht.
Serious Marks doch, das habe ich daheim.
Das verwende ich daheim zum Streams gucken und im WLAN.
Unterwegs habe ich das iPhone 6 dabei, weil es leichter ist.
Aber heute haben sie sich ja voll aufgeregt auf Twitter.
Und ich habe ein iPhone 6, ich kann die Corona-App nicht installieren.
So eine Scheiße, warum hat es 20 Millionen gekostet?
Und da habe ich mir das mal so durchgelenkt.
Es ist doch klar, warum das unter iOS, also auf dem iPhone 6 nicht läuft.
Wenn die Sachen brauchen, die iOS 13 zwingend voraussetzen,
dann gibt es, es gibt nun mal kein iOS 13 für 32-Bit-Geräte.
Und das iPhone 6 ist, glaube ich, das letzte 32-Bit-Gerät gewesen.
Gibt es halt nicht.
Dann brauchen die spezielles Bluetooth-Zeug dafür, dass es funktioniert.
Ich glaube, da hat das iPhone 6 noch nicht mal die Hardware für drinnen.
Und da müssen die sich halt den Apple-Bedingungen anpassen.
Also, ich weiß nicht, es wäre natürlich cool,
wenn das jetzt auf jedem x-beliebigen Nokia 1355, oder wie hieß das?
Wie hieß dieses Ding nochmal?
1355, war das 1350?
Das Fette, das Fünfte, das Fette.
Nee, das meine ich nicht.
Wie hieß das?
33310, genau.
Ah, echt, nee, das meine ich nicht.
Das meine ich nicht.
Ich meine das richtig, das richtig Fette, Alte.
Fett.
Alt.
Oh nee, da gehe ich jetzt nicht auf Bilder-Suche.
Wenn ich jetzt auf Images drücke, Leute, ist es echt problematisch,
wenn ich nach Fett und Alt suche.
Dann sehen wir Sachen, die wollen wir nicht sehen, glaube ich.
Hahaha.
D-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d.
Wie hieß das denn?
Nokia, nee, nee, 33, äh, 33110?
Das, so was hier in der Richtung meine ich.
Das, wobei das ist das doch.
Sowas hier meine ich, so ein richtig dickes Fettes.
Weil, warum ist das in 3310 und das in 3310?
Das sind doch komplett unterschiedliche.
Da liegen noch 5, 6 Jahre zwischen den 2 Handys.
33, das war das C?
Nee, ich meine das richtig.
Okay, okay.
Wir gucken jetzt Nokia Handler History.
Ich zeige euch, welches ich meine.
Das hatte ich ja auch damals.
Sowas.
Nee, nee, nicht sowas.
Das ist schon ein bisschen neuer.
Doch.
3110.
Doch, das meine ich.
Genau das meine ich.
Das hatte ich auch.
Das stimmt dann halt einfach.
Die Anzeige hier, die ist fail.
Das meine ich, genau.
Es wäre natürlich cool, wenn die Corona App noch auf sowas laufen würde.
Aber ich kann es verstehen, wenn man sich an halbwegs aktuellen Sachen orientiert.
Vor allem, wenn die Geräte halt manche Hardware-Funktionen gar nicht haben, die man dafür braucht.
Also insofern.
Was willst du machen, ja?
Nein, das ist ein 3310C Classic.
Achso.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Aber das war mein erstes Handy, was ich hatte.
Also das konntest du noch als Waffe verwenden damals.
Also das war...
Also...
Also wenn du das einem gegen den Kopf geschmissen hast, der hat was gemerkt.
Du meinst, dass Dynatech...
Was?
Nein, nein, nein.
Was meinst du?
Was ist das?
Das ist sowas, was man in der Wüste verwendet.
Okay, das meine ich nicht.
Das sieht aus, wie irgendwas vor den Atombomben mit scharf machen kannst.
Das sieht aus, als was aus der Modern Warfight Kampagne.
Leute, wer ist so alt?
Wer ist so alt? Und kann sich noch dran erinnern?
Also nicht da dran.
Ähm, an Leute, die damals richtig cool waren,
Weil sie nen Autotelefon hatten?
Autotelefon?
Macht das hier mal noch was?
Auto, Telefon?
So was hier?
Wo sich alle wahnsinnig geil vorkamen, weil es ein Auto... also die, die es hatten, ja, und das war auch Schweine teuer, ja.
Ich frage mich immer noch heute, wie das eigentlich genau funktioniert hat. War das in eine Satellitengeschichte oder so?
Hatte Opas Auto? Wenn du das hatte, hat dein Opa, hatte der hier Easy Money, Easy Life.
Mein Auto-Telefon, das war Schweine teuer damals.
Ich frag mich, wie man ein Auto-Telefon gemacht hat damals, pre-Mobilfunk.
Oder war das schon Mobilfunk, war das der erste Mobilfunk-Standard überhaupt?
Ich hab mich nie damit beschäftigt, keine Ahnung.
Oh, googlew.de ist keine gute Idee, diese Domains sind immer schön verseucht mit Viren und Sachen.
Ja, damals hat sich keiner dafür interessiert, dass Leute am Steuer telefoniert haben.
Das war denen auch wurscht.
Geschäftswagen, easy.
Warum highlightet eigentlich dieser Chat hier nicht ein bisschen Source-Code angucken?
Von der Corona-App, ich weiß nicht, ob das so spannend ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so spannend ist. Hier haben wir die iOS-Variante, hier haben wir die Android-Variante.
Dann gibt es hier die Java, muss es ausgerechnet Java sein?
Leute, das war Kaniel und Sebaus, war klar, dass das schon wieder irgendwie Minenfeld-Seite ist.
Die Corona-Warn-Webseite, ich glaube, da können wir nicht großartig was gucken.
Erstens habe ich von Mobile-Apps jetzt nicht so den Wahnsinnsplan.
Ich habe weder bisher eine richtige iOS-App noch eine richtige Android-App gebastelt, also eine richtig echte, quasi sowas Java-mäßiges und sowas Objective-C oder Swift-mäßiges.
Das Einzige, was ich mal gemacht habe, ist eine PWA gebaut, aber das ist ja webgedönst, das geht ja als App gar nicht durch.
Die Musik ist voll MonkaS gerade.
MonkaS-Musik.
Das Logo habe ich mir noch überhaupt nicht angeguckt.
Das Logo, ja an was erinnert mich das Logo?
Also es erinnert mich auf jeden Fall nicht an Corona.
Es sieht aus wie warm, warm-kalt, Himmel, so Himmel, vielleicht könnte es eine Bibel-App sein, Himmel-Hölle, so.
Oder es könnte ein Auge sein, guck mal, es könnte ein Auge sein, wo ein Stück fehlt.
Seht ihr das? In der Mitte, hier Auge und dann irgendwie so, so eine Art schon Special-Ninja-Auge.
Fieber-Packman, es könnte auch sein.
Fieber-Packman finde ich eine sinnvolle Erklärung dafür.
Also an Corona würde ich nicht wirklich denken, wenn ich das Logo sehe.
So, ich glaube da können wir uns hier nicht allzu viel angucken.
Wo ist eigentlich die, wo ist denn die richtige App jetzt drinne?
Hier, Source, oh Gott, Java, Java-Namespaces, hör mal auf, geh doch weg, geh doch weg, Alter, geh weg.
Guckt euch das mal an, das ist doch absolute Zumutung.
Risk, oh Risk klingt gut.
Die Musik ist ein bisschen laut, oder? Heute.
Aber so.
So, Risk-Level, KT.
Was ist, was ist K, ist das Kotlin, Kotlin? Ja, das ist Kotlin.
Companion-Object, ich dachte eigentlich Kotlin sieht hübscher aus.
Das sieht ja, das sieht ja eklig aus.
Fun, also das finde ich nicht schön zu lesen.
Ich dachte Kotlin will hübscher sein als Java.
Was ist denn das hier? Doppelpunkt bool?
Ist das der Return-Wert? Ist das der Return-Wert?
Parameter, Name-Parameter, Name-Parameter 1, Name-Parameter 2.
Warum ist das denn Zeilen umgebrochen hier?
Macht man das so?
Bricht man hier die Zeilen in der Funktions-Deklaration um?
Das ist bestimmt ein komischer Coding-Style, den SAP verwendet.
Den normalerweise kein Mensch verwendet.
Und mal irgendeine andere Datei an, ob es da besser ausschaut.
Ja, so, so verstehe ich das.
So leuchtet mir das ein.
Alter, was ist das? Ja, das sieht eklig aus.
Okay, das leuchtet mir jetzt ein.
Private-Methode, warum es auch immer Funktion ist.
Was auch immer, wir wollen das jetzt mal nicht so sehr hinterfragen.
Über 120 Zeilen ist der Kotlin-Standard.
Okay, kann man sich drüber streiten.
Bei Linux hat letztens jetzt Linus selbst mal ein Machtwort gesprochen.
Weil wir da Leute angefangen haben mit über 80 Zeichen.
Über 80 zeichenlange Zeilen sollen umgebrochen werden, hat er gesagt.
Leute, er hat in einem etwas längeren Kommentar auf der Linux-Mailing-Liste quasi das hier gesagt.
Und damit war die Sache vom Tisch.
Man muss aber sagen, Linus war ja bekannt für, dass er früher mal öfters ein bisschen rumgeraged hat.
Und sich auch mal ein bisschen die Leute beleidigt hat und sich aufgeregt hat und noch ein bisschen mehr die Leute beleidigt hat.
Ich meine, wer es kennt, das Video ist, wo er was erzählt, fuck you NVIDIA und zeigt ihr Mittelfinger.
Er war schon dafür bekannt ein bisschen zu ragen.
Aber jetzt hat er vor einem Jahr oder zwei Jahren, ist schon ein bisschen her.
Hat er gesagt, er wird sich zurückziehen und quasi in sich gehen und mal versuchen, das hinzugehen.
Man muss sagen, er sagt immer noch relativ deutlich, was kacke ist.
Aber er flamet nicht mehr so sinnlos rum.
Also man muss sagen, so seine Selbstfindung hat funktioniert.
Ja.
Naja, aber ich glaube die Corona-App, wie sieht denn das Ganze für die iOS-App aus?
Wo ist die iOS-App überhaupt drinne?
Source Xcode bestimmt.
Fastlane.
Nee, das war was anderes.
Das ist irgendwelche Branch-Geschichten.
Wo ist denn die eigentliche App jetzt hier drinne?
In welchem Ort?
War doch richtig?
ENA?
Da hätte ich ja im Leben nicht reingeguckt.
Was ist denn ENA?
Ist das quasi DNA?
Nur für Apple oder?
Apple-DNA-Format?
Okay, Source.
Extra Nice App.
Ah, exzellent, verstehe.
Services.
Wir gucken jetzt mal irgendwie.
Reachability Service.
Also wenn das Java wäre, da bräuchte man mindestens eine Reachability Service Factory Singleton dafür.
Okay, wo ist ein bisschen Logik drinne?
Wir brauchen ein bisschen Logik.
Risk Level scheint da ganz furchtbar angesagt zu sein.
Viel schöner sieht das jetzt ehrlich gesagt.
Da war nicht aus.
Was ist denn hier ein bisschen Logik drinne?
Ist hier Logik drinne?
War auch nicht wirklich.
Aber ein bisschen, bisschen Scenes.
Hier scheint ein bisschen Logik drinne zu sein.
Okay, ehrlich gesagt sieht es auch nicht viel schöner aus.
Aber ich gehe davon aus, dass es tatsächlich sowohl in Kotlin als auch in Swift jeweils recht ordentlich programmiert ist.
Für mich sieht es plötzlich so schön aus, weil ich beide Sprachen nicht gewohnt bin.
Man versteht es, man kann es halt lesen.
Das ist auch so eine Sache, wo ich sagen muss, das ist ein Vorteil, wenn man 1-2 Programmiersprachen ganz gut kann.
Du kannst alle anderen, die ansatzweise ähnlich sind, also 90%, kannst du zumindest lesen.
Nicht unbedingt schreiben, du kennst die Standard-Libraries, du kennst keine Namespaces, du kennst keine Funktionen richtig.
Aber du kannst den Kram alles lesen.
Ja gut, es kommt einer mit sowas wie Erlang an.
Ich habe noch letztens gesagt, wir machen mal dieses Quiz da.
Wo hatten wir es denn? War das das hier?
Das ist aber nämlich am Ende vom letzten Stream, da wurde einem der letzten Streams gemacht, da hatte ich keine Zeit mehr.
Nazana sagt, möchte dieses Jahr noch Python 3 lernen.
Das ist eine gute Einstiegssprache.
So, also wenn mal einer was sehen will, was eklig aussieht, der muss ich Erlang angucken.
Ah, exzellent.
Ich hoffe jetzt ist alles klar, oder?
Ich meine, der Mathematik-Professor ist wahrscheinlich pleased, wenn er das sieht und freut sich dann wahnsinnig.
Für mich sieht es doch schon hardcore und leserlich aus.
Lisp, Lisp ist auch so ein Ding, was auch direkt aus der Hölle kommt.
Aber Lisp, haben wir da ein schönes Beispiel für.
Wir brauchen ein bisschen besseres.
Lisp, Lisp und war das Scala?
Ich glaube Scala, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Irgendwas, was auch total auf Klammern steht.
Klammern, exzellent.
Ich habe letztens gesagt, ich mag Klammern, aber meine Lieblingsklammern sind eindeutig die C-Style Block-Klammern.
Lisp ist auch abadisch.
Aber Erlang ist wirklich absolut zum Fürchten.
Wir hatten mal eine Software auf der Arbeit, die war in Erlang programmiert.
Das war irgendeine Key-Value-Store-Distributed-Database.
Nannt es sich React-Database oder so?
NoSQL-Database.
Und das war glaube ich auch in Erlang.
Der Hersteller ist irgendwann pleite gegangen davon.
Wir hatten Support vom Hersteller.
Die nannten sich lustigerweise Bashow.
Die haben das dann irgendwann eingestellt, den Support, und sind pleite gegangen.
Wir mussten uns damals, das weiß ich noch, um Sachen erweitern zu können, weil Erlang keiner unserer krassen Java-Entwickler in der Lage war.
Haben sie sich damals glaube ich aus der Schweiz so einen Experte extra einfliegen lassen, der Sachen für die gemacht hat.
Das hat irgendwie 150k gekostet oder so, nur dass der Typ was macht.
Wenn man zu viel Geld hat, ne.
Scala-Example.
Scala ist auch eklig.
Code-Examples.
Das ist die offizielle Example-Seite.
Da würden wir davon ausgehen, dass es wirklich sehr hübsch ist.
So viel hat sich da bestimmt nicht getan.
Das sieht doch ganz hübsch aus.
Das geht doch noch.
Erlang und Lisp.
Gerade Lisp.
Ich hab ja früher ein bisschen Emacs verwendet.
Die komplette Emacs-Konfiguration ist Lisp.
Und das ist wirklich eklig gewesen.
Mich wunderts nicht, dass der Kram sich nicht großartig durchgesetzt hat in der Breite in den letzten Jahren.
Weil die Leute hatten zunehmend die Auswahl zwischen Lisp und Javascript.
Und auch wenn ich kein großer Javascript-Fan bin.
Aber wenn ich die Auswahl habe zwischen Javascript und Lisp.
Also dann ist die Wahl doch wirklich klar Javascript.
Kennst du Groovy? Ja.
Ich hab auf der Arbeit eine Art Confluence-Plugin gebastelt in Groovy.
Das Einzige, was ich je auf der JVM gemacht habe.
Oh Easykiller, das ist das Pains-Champ.
Das ist richtig Pains-Champ.
Ich find das Emote gerade nicht. Ich hab zu viele Emotes drin.
Wo ist mein Pains-Champ-Emote?
Leute, Pains-Champ ist weg.
Findet ihr ihn? Wo ist er?
Ach da.
Ich hab zu viele Emotes.
Zu viele Emotes.
Der wichtigste Emote ist natürlich ganz vorne.
Sebaro, was sind Swiftgrills?
Also unsere iOS-Entwicklerin.
Bei uns in der iOS-App-Entwicklung sind verhältnisvolle Mädels im Vergleich zu allen anderen IT-Sektoren.
Oder wie man das nennt, Abteilungen.
So, das hat er mal.
Auf dem Staubsauger.
Auf dem Staubsauger müsste eventuell irgendeine Android-Variante laufen.
Übrigens mein Staubsauger.
Mal gucken, ob er noch geht.
Mal gucken, ob er noch funktioniert.
Ja, exellent.
Staubsauger erlädt.
Letztes Mal hat er 20 Minuten gestaubsaugert.
Kartenleak vom Wohnzimmer.
Perfekt.
Kann man Staubsauger wieder zumachen.
Was ist Spotreinigung?
Da kannst du ihn auf der Map auf eine Stelle schicken und dann macht er halt die Stelle so im Kreis sauber.
Was hast du für einen Staubsauger?
Ein Show Me Roborock S50.
Und wir haben den sogar mal im Stream geflasht irgendwann.
Ja.
Exellent.
Kann sogar wischen, verwende ich aber nicht.
Wie wäre es mit Story of Lulvee vs. Kekwee?
Was?
Das da?
The Story of Lulvee vs. Kekwee is a story many don't like to tell.
Was ist das denn?
Was ist das?
Okay, das gucken wir uns gleich an.
Das gucken wir uns an.
Okay, vorher machen wir aber eine Runde nochmal Programmiersprachen Quiz.
Vor allem aber eine Runde noch Programmiersprachen Quiz und gucken, wie weit wir heute kommen hier.
Und abgucken ist nicht erlaubt.
Also ich kann nicht nebenbei googeln.
Was ich aber machen darf ist, ich darf Chat lesen.
Und der Chat, wie wir alle wissen, ist natürlich das hilfreichste auf ganz Twitch.
Der Chat würde einen niemals gibaken beantworten.
Weil kommt endlich das Minecraft-Schaubesauger-Video.
Das läuft nicht.
Es läuft kein Java drauf.
Richtig.
Kein modernes Java.
Okay, Play.
Also, was ist das?
IO-Putz klingt nach Ruby, ist es aber nicht.
Also es ist kein Lisp.
Zu wenig Klammern.
Erlangen wird es auch nicht sein.
Alexia.
Ich sage es ist Alexia.
Excellent.
Das könnte Lisp sein.
Es ist kein Java.
Clojure ist auch so eine komische Klammern-Sprache.
Es könnte Clojure oder Lisp sein.
Patrick, es gibt doch gar kein C++ zur Auswahl.
Es ist, es könnte, ich tendiere zu Lisp.
Es könnte aber auch Clojure sein.
Fuck, es ist Clojure.
So, next.
Es ist aber schwer der Anfang diesmal.
Haskell.
Chet.
Putzdrillen.
Das klingt tatsächlich ein bisschen nach.
Ja, Main.
Das ist wirklich Haskell.
Display-Dialog.
Hello World.
Apple-Script.
Es ist kein JavaScript.
Wobei mich nicht wundern würde, dass das irgendwie ein JavaScript-gültiger Code wäre.
Das ist C.
Ne, das ist Objective-C.
Das ist Objective-C.
Apple.
Apple ist das.
Das ist Objective-C.
NS-Log.
NS-Log ist ein Deutsch Objective-C.
Das ist Objective-C, Leute.
Wow, was ist denn das für eine...
Object-Pascal-Example.
Ist das...
Das ist Verarschung, oder?
Das ist Delphi anstatt Pascal.
Oder?
Delphi und Pascal sind sich ziemlich ähnlich.
Procedure-Begin-End.
Delphi.
Exzellent.
Das ist...
Es ist nicht C-Sharp.
Ich meine, es wäre eventuell...
Ne, es wäre noch nicht mal gültiger C-Sharp-Code.
Es sieht aber auch nicht wirklich aus wie Java, oder?
Das ist bestimmt Phantom.
Weil ich Phantom noch nie gesehen habe.
Aber Java ist es nicht.
Java ist doch auch so was wie...
Wie Console Printline oder so.
Das ist bestimmt Phantom.
Ja, passt.
Jetzt, das ist Lisp.
Der Phantom...
Das ist Lisp, Leute.
Jetzt ist es Lisp.
Bam.
Was?
Ist das Shakespeare?
Das könnte Home Spring sein.
Universe Beer Hatchery Powers World.
Hatchery Powers...
Oh, das ist bestimmt Shakespeare, hä?
Nein, Home Spring.
Let Hello World gleich Hello World.
Prince...
Swift?
Chat, was meint ihr?
Ich sage Swift.
Home Swift.
Bam.
Ruby.
Das ist Ruby.
What?
Fancy.
Ich habe jetzt gedacht, das ist Ruby.
Das sieht schon sehr ähnlich aus.
Nein, das ist kein Ruby.
Weil Ruby müsstest du...
Ruby müsstest du so, glaube ich, machen.
Irgendwie...
Ich habe eh gar nicht Ruby mehr gemacht.
Das F-Sharp?
Nein.
Das ist aber schwer heute.
Chat, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
F-Sharp?
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass es F-Sharp ist.
Nein.
Oh, Kammel ist auch was Funktionales irgendwie.
Das sieht nicht so funktional aus.
Vielleicht ist es Standard ML?
Ich habe keinen Plastenschimmer, was Standard ML ist.
Ah, Standard ML.
Ha.
Okay, wir haben die...
Also er wird es nicht sein.
Wir haben die Auswahl zwischen OMG Roffel.
Was ist das für ein bescheuertes Quiz, Alter?
Wir haben die Auswahl zwischen HQ9 Plus und OMG Roffel.
Ich meine, wenn da ein H drinne steht und es ist HQ9 Plus, dann nehmen wir einfach HQ9 Plus.
Es war...
Ja.
Easy.
Um nicht zu sagen...
Okay, was haben wir hier zu bieten?
Hello?
Hello...
Force?
Also es sieht nicht so nach Erlang aus, oder?
Könnte es doch Erlang sein?
Force.
Force ist es.
Ah, nice.
Post... das ist Postscript.
Das ist Postscript, Leute.
Was sagt ihr?
Ich sag, das ist Postscript.
Postscript ist das für Drucker.
Chat hat keine Ahnung.
Bash war noch nicht dabei, ne?
Ich sag, das ist Postscript.
Passende Musik dazu.
Okay, Postscript.
Hi.
Ken?
Hass?
Das ist bestimmt LOL-Code.
Es könnte auch Befunsch sein.
Ich kenn beides nicht.
Case Thank Spy klingt irgendwie nach LOL-Code.
Excellent.
LOL-Code.
Brainfuck ist es nicht.
Brainfuck ist der Kram hier.
Brainfuck erkennt man, wenn man Brainfuck erkennt.
Import Java-Utils.
Sieht so eine Methodendefinition in Java aus?
Nee, oder?
Das ist G-Bait.
Extend.
Ich kenn Extend nicht.
Ah, aber es ist Extend.
D-Dataset.
Hello World.
String-Value.
ECL?
Ich mein, es ist weder C, es ist noch Pascal.
Das muss ECL sein.
ECL.
Ja.
Das ist C-Sharp.
Es kann kein C sein.
Es kann auch kein C++ sein.
Das ist C-Sharp.
C-Lattenzaun.
Print-Endline.
O-Kammel?
Oder weder Standard-ML?
Oh, das weiß ich nicht.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Ich tendiere zu O-Kammel.
Oder O-Cammel, wie man immer das ausspricht.
Ich weiß es aber ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Warum ich darauf tippe ist, weil wir jetzt die ähnliche Frage schon mal hatten und das
ist weder Standard-ML.
Allerdings muss man sagen, dass O-Kammel auch was Funktionales ist und ich glaube auch was
mit vielen Klammern.
Das heißt vielleicht ist es auch weder Standard-ML.
F-Sharp ist eine Funktionale.NET-Programmiersprache.
Okay Chat, ich nehm weder Standard-ML.
Ich nehm weder Standard-ML, weil ich finde es sieht überhaupt nicht Funktional aus.
Es kann auch sein, dass wir richtig verkehrt liegen.
F-Sharp.
O-Kammel.
Vorbei.
Okay, ein Leben haben wir noch.
Ein Leben haben wir noch.
Okay, das ist nicht C.
Das ist nicht C und das ist nicht Go.
Das muss Dart sein.
Go waren die Methodendefinition anders.
Und Print hat man gemacht in Go mit FMT, FMT, Printeln oder sowas.
Das muss Dart sein.
Ja.
Hello World Posteln.
Okay, jetzt bin ich echt am Ende von meinem Knowledge angekommen.
Ich habe keinen Plastenschimmer.
Das könnte alles sein.
Von Super Collider habe ich noch nie was gehört.
Matlab kenne ich, habe ich aber noch nicht verwendet.
Processing sagt mir auch gar nichts.
So, nachdem ich finde es sieht nicht nach Mathe aus.
Und nachdem ich Super Collider nicht kenne, würde ich sagen es ist Processing.
Fuck.
Super Collider.
Alter, was ist das für eine Sprache, da hat er doch keine Sau was von gehört.
Was ist so, soll das ein Super Collider sein?
Realtime Audio.
Das, das kennt doch kein Mensch.
Okay, es hat sogar ein GitHub-Account.
Und es ist vor ein paar Tagen erst Version 3 als 1 rausgekommen.
Und es hat 3,2k Sterne, okay.
Okay, ich gebe zu, es besteht die Chance, dass man es kennt.
Patrick sagt sein Bruder arbeitet, er hätte mir doch mal was verraten können jetzt.
Oder wusste es selbst nicht wahrscheinlich.
Super Collider.
Alter, meine Güte.
Gibt es so ein Highscore?
Easiest Language Apple Script, Hardest Language Nemale hatten wir gar nicht.
Highscore 7500?
Was ist der Durchschnittsscore?
Okay, das ist hart, das ist hart, also, nee.
Quizzes for Programming Language.
Java.
Boah, geh weg.
Okay, also, Chat, ich hab's euch ja versprochen, wir gucken jetzt Story of Lulvee vs. Kekvi an.
X-Danklight, 4 Monate, excellent subscription, huge.
Eigentlich für den Sub.
Und ich muss mal kurz schauen, dass ich nicht was vergessen hab.
Super Collider hast du schon vor ein paar Wochen mal gegoogelt, echt?
Okay, kann sein, sowas merke ich mir meistens nicht.
Das ist so Nischensprache irgendwie.
Wobei, so Nische kann es gar nicht sein mit 3,2 Sterne auf GitHub.
Na doch, kanns schon.
Gut, schauen wir uns das mal an.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Story of Lulvee vs. Kekvee.
Ich ahne ja Schlimmes.
Wir sind hier natürlich quasi Lach-E-Mode divers, wir haben verschiedenste Sachen.
Wir haben Lul 3D zu bieten, wir haben Lul zu bieten, wir haben Kekvee zu bieten.
Alles, alles da hier, haben wir.
Okay.
Es geht ja schon gut los, Alter.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob die Lautstärke passt, wartet mal kurz.
Der Anfang ist ja geil, der Anfang ist ja geil.
Vor allem, vor allem wie gut er die Sounds auch gemacht hat mit den Lauf-E-Modes, ne?
Vor allem ist das auch gerade das Mokka-S oder ist ja ein Mokka-W, ist es ja.
Silly-Champ.
Die Leute sind schon kreativ.
Die Primers.
Die Primers?
Gibt es das noch? Gibt es, gibt es Hitbox noch?
Das muss ich gleich mal nachgucken.
Slater Daddy, vier Monate Dankeschön, excellent Subscription.
Big Brain.
Das ist richtig gut gemacht.
Hey, du.
Also kreativ ist der Typ, das muss man belassen.
Das muss man belassen.
Du.
Das war ja ein geiles Video.
Da hätte ich jetzt echt nicht mit.
Warum hat das nur 1.970 Views?
Ist das ein Reupload?
So Twitch-Blödsinn hat doch normalerweise mindestens 150k oder so.
Warum hat das nur 2.000 Views?
Das ist auch richtig gut gemacht.
Das muss ich gleich mal likeboten.
Warte nur bis ein großer Streamer draufreaktet.
Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt.
Wenn da erstmal ein Gold oder irgendwelche Leute anfangen drauf zu reacten,
dann hat es danach wieder gleich mehr.
Das war aber richtig gut.
Das ist richtig gut gemacht.
Vor allem der Anfang ist geil.
Mit dem Hallen-Effekt.
Richtig steiles Video.
Keg W.
Oh Mann.
Was die alles gibt.
Wann war nochmal die Apple-Konferenz-Keynote, die wir uns angucken wollten?
Events.
22.
Also ich bin ja immer noch der Meinung, dass 0W größer Keg W ist.
Allerdings Keg W hat einen unbestreitbaren Vorteil.
Es hat einen Sound.
Und der Sound passt definitiv nicht zu 0.
Jetzt geht es im Chat auch los hier.
Ich habe Schluck auf.
Und jetzt?
Patrick, nicht die Leute timeouten, die 0W besser finden.
Keine Modrechte missbrauchen hier.
Warum habe ich denn Schluck auf?
What the fuck.
Ja.
Der aber sagt, er möchte einen Tracker machen, kommt aber nicht mit der API klar.
Ich kann es mal angucken, aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich mit der API klarkomme.
Knärbär, mach das mal weg, da ist dein API-Key drinnen.
Knärbär, du hast dein API-Key mit gepostet.
Der API-Key ist egal, okay.
Die letzte Nachricht Leuchten hätte jetzt auch gereicht.
Also API-Key-Leak war...
Wenn der API-Key egal ist, kannst du nochmal posten.
Wir wollten dich ja nur vor dir selbst beschützen.
Okay, also was hat Knärbär hier geschickt?
Excellent, Steam-API, schon nie verwendet.
Response, Players, Steam-ID, ja das sieht nachher ein ganz normaler Chasen-Response aus.
Und weiter.
Das ist ein ganz normaler Chasen-Response, wo ist das Problem?
Da steht der Name drin, echt? Tatsächlich.
Woher weiß Steam denn den realen Name?
Weiß der das bei mir auch?
Kann er nicht wissen, weil ich hab mich mit Mr. Wubblors angemeldet.
Das stimmt, du hast recht, ja klar. Firefox ist Poggers, was das angeht.
Okay.
Warte mal.
Ich hab noch ein richtig geiles Video gesehen letztens zu Mario 64 Speedrun-Strat.
Aber vorher gucken wir uns noch was anderes an.
Hab ich auch vorhin erst gefunden.
Und zwar MMO-Spielerzahlen der letzten 23 Jahre.
Allerdings hab ich so meine Zweifel, wie korrekt die sind, so ab 2010.
Aber das mal kurz an. Find ich nämlich recht interessant.
So, das war vor meiner MMO-Zeit, da hab ich noch keine MMOs gespielt zu der ganzen Geschichte.
JRPGs, nee nee nee, World of Warcrafts, immer noch das Ding schlechthin.
Dezember 2019, da hab ich, was hab ich da gemacht?
Noch nicht Half-Life gespielt, weil Half-Life gab's noch nicht.
Starcraft, Starcraft vielleicht?
Ich hab, ich hab, Realm Online hab ich nie gespielt, kenn ich nicht.
Ultima Online kenn ich, hab ich auch nicht gespielt.
Lineage, oh jetzt kommen die Asiatinger, jetzt kommen die Asiatinger.
Das war, das war ein riesen Game damals, das war ein absolut riesen Game.
Das war so ein 24-7-Grind-MMO.
Everquest, gut klar, das kommt also in der Zeit auch.
Jetzt kommt, ja das dauert jetzt noch ein bisschen.
So irgendwann kommt dann noch Dark Age of Camelot, das dauert aber noch so zwei Jahre.
Aber das, das, das haben sie ja verkackt, das hat EA ja wieder, das hat EA so verschissen zwischendurch.
Aber guckt euch mal an, das erste Hype-MMO quasi so mit richtig Millionen Zuschauern war so ein Asia-Kreisel-Grinder.
Ich weiß nicht ob das drinnen steht, Patrick, solange die, solange die Zahlen veröffentlicht haben, müsste das drinnen stehen.
Ok, da tut sich nicht viel, Everquest.
Ash und Scorla hab ich auch noch nicht gespielt.
Everquest ist auf jeden Fall relativ beliebt gewesen in der Zeit.
World War II Online.
Was ist das denn, hab ich auch noch nie was von gehört.
Sowas wie Battlefield oder was?
Ah, excellent graphics.
Alles klar.
World War II Online.
Ok, was, was es nicht alles gibt.
Hier, bestes, bestes MMO aller Zeiten.
Leider nur für zwei, drei Jahre, weil es EA total verschissen hat.
Mal wieder.
Guckt mal, Dark auf richtig, auf richtig aufsteigenden Ast, ne?
So, ich mein, das ist alles, das ist alles noch Pre-World of Warcraft, das heißt MMOs sind im Westen noch nicht so wahnsinnig, so wahnsinnig angekommen, ja?
2002 sind wir grad.
Ach, sieht man das im Chat nicht?
Ist der Chat drüber?
Ach, der Chat ist drüber, warte mal, warte mal, ich mach, müsst ihr mir sagen, ich mach grad noch mal ein Stückchen zurück, mach mal den Chat kurz raus.
So.
Hier, Dark, bestes MMO aller Zeiten.
Motor City Online hab ich eigentlich noch nie davon gehört.
Aber da waren, im Westen waren MMOs noch nicht so angesagt zur damaligen Zeit.
Die Asiaten haben hier schon Kreisel Grind 24-7 gemacht.
In Lineage.
Lineage.
Lineage, Lineage.
Lineage ist der Android, ist die Android-Geschichte, Lineage ist das MMO.
Oh Gott, RuneScape von OKS.
Hier, Dark ging richtig gut ab mal ne Zeit lang und die haben so verschissen damals, war echt heftig.
Ab hier ging's schon wieder abwärts, das Game hatte so Potenzial, die haben so heftigst verschissen auch.
Ok, Final Fantasy, klar.
So und jetzt, irgendwann, demnächst muss doch auch World of Warcraft kommen.
Nächstes Jahr oder so kommt WoW glaube.
2004, 2004, 2005, irgendwie so was muss doch WoW gekommen sein.
Shadowbane, das wurde damals auch voll als Next Level Shit gehandelt und war dann kacke.
Genau, ich glaube viel mehr, Dark müsste noch ein Ticken mehr erreichen.
Aber das hat stagniert, jetzt kommt gleich WoW irgendwann.
Das ärgert mich bis heute, wie sehr die das verschissen haben mit Dark Edge of Camelot.
Das ist meiner Ansicht immer noch das beste MMO und eines der wenigen MMOs mit quasi nahezu endlosem Endgame, weil es PvP Endgame ist.
Und auch PvP Endgame, was jeder Noob spielen kann.
Konntest einfach rumzergen mit 40 Mann, meinen wegen.
Die hätten das ausbauen müssen, die haben den großen Fehler gemacht in Dark.
Ich muss jetzt mal ein bisschen Cool Story Max machen.
Die haben damals den großen Fehler in Dark gemacht.
Die haben ein MMO, was 60% PvP Endgame war, 40% PvM umgebaut zu einem Spiel, was einen riesen Zwangspvm Anteil hatte.
Und da hatten die Leute keinen Bock drauf.
Es wäre überhaupt kein Problem gewesen, hätte man das eingebaut, allerdings es war Pflicht.
Du konntest quasi ein dreiviertel Jahr nicht das Spiel spielen, was du spielen wolltest, weil du Gear farmen musstest.
Und das war für die damalige Zeit in dem Spiel, das kam echt nicht gut an.
Und außerdem kam World of Warcraft jetzt gleich und dann war eh MMO Schicht im Schacht.
Guck mal, wie schnell das runterfällt und World of Warcraft geht durch die Decke.
Das waren dann so die Zeiten hier, wo auch beim ersten Addon dann im Media Markt die Scheiben gebrochen sind und sowas noch.
Damals hat sich Jeff Kaplan noch auf die Bühne gestellt in der BlizzCon und hat gesagt, man soll schlechte Spieler aus der Gruppe kicken.
Könnt ihr euch Blizzard 2020 vorstellen, dass jemand dort es wagen würde, auf der Bühne zu sagen, man soll schlechte Spieler aus der Gruppe kicken, da würde das Internet explodieren.
Da kommen die ersten Leute wieder an und sagen, schlechte Spieler werden diskriminiert.
Dann kommt der nächste an und sagt, vielleicht ist es ja ein Spieler mit Handicap, ihr diskriminiert Behinderte.
Dann kommt der nächste an und sagt, vielleicht ist es ein schwarzer Spieler mit Handicap, ihr diskriminiert Schwarze und Behinderte.
Und Blizzard, warum könnt ihr es überhaupt wagen? Jeder soll das Spiel spielen, wie er will, ihr könnt es den Leuten doch nicht aufzwingen.
Blizzard, ich kaufe nie wieder ein Produkt von euch. Blizzard, ich hasse euch. Blizzard, ihr seid die schlimmste Worst Company ever.
Die würden total eskalieren wieder, die Leute.
Damals stellte sich Jeff Kaplan einfach auf die Bühne und sagte, Leute, ihr kennt das, ihr habt schlechte Spieler in der Gruppe.
Er hat ihnen ein Beispiel gebracht, so nach dem Motto, ihr kennt das doch sicher, ihr habt einen Heiler in der Gruppe, der nie heilt.
Oder irgendwie sowas hat er erzählt.
Und dann hat er danach gesagt, man soll die Leute einfach kicken.
Und das würde er sich nie trauen heute.
Ok, ja gut, jetzt geht WoW erstmal durch die Decke.
Das war klar.
Dark ist komplett raus.
Was man hier aber schön sieht ist, dass sowohl Ultima Online als auch Everquest, die vorher da waren, Everquest 2 hält sich übrigens nicht lang.
Dass sie und auch Eve Online, dass die es geschafft haben, die sind nie in Millionen Bereiche gegangen wie World of Warcraft.
Aber die haben relativ konstant ihre Leute gehalten.
Ich meine Ultima Online kackt jetzt ein bisschen ab, aber gerade Everquest und RuneScape, die halten ihre Leute lang.
Second Life war mal kurz da und ist wieder weg.
Vielleicht erinnert sich noch einer an Second Life, wo dann auch angefangen hat irgendwie BMW und sonst was digitale Niederlassungen aufzumachen und so.
Second Life, eines der schlechtesten, überhyptesten Games ohne Sinn irgendwie dahinter der letzten 15 Jahre.
So ein Schwachsinn, Patrick, das war richtig low.
Second Life war so ein richtig dummes Ding, wo jeder, der ein bisschen Ahnung von MMOs hatte und ein paar MMOs gespielt hat, von Anfang an gesagt hat, so ein Scheiß, niemand wird spielen.
Und es hat im Endeffekt auch keiner gespielt hat.
So alle, second life, second life, ok, second life wieder weg.
So ein bisschen wie vor Corona, wir haben so viel Geld, vier Wochen Corona, aber wir haben kein Geld.
Genau so schnell, genau so schnell, hatte Second Life, wie hießen die nochmal, Linden Labs oder so, hatten die Geld und waren wieder weg vom Fenster.
Dofus, Alter, was war denn das?
Ist das nicht auch irgendwie so ein Anime-MMO gewesen?
Guck, Second Life ist gleich wieder weg.
Dauert nicht mehr lang, dann ist es weg.
So, Warcraft geht durch die Decke.
Und jetzt geht es abwärts hier.
City of Heroes habe ich noch nie gehört.
Age of Conan war auch so ein Fail, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Age of Conan, Alter, das kam raus, das kam raus und damals die Leute richtig gehyped drauf, wir müssen uns das nochmal angucken.
Guck mal hier, das Game war richtig hype und danach wieder weg.
Also was bei Age of Conan, kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Hier, das kommt raus das Game und hatte eine super high-polished Tutorial-Insel.
Das ging so 20 Stunden oder so, ich klicke das immer genau zusammen.
Wirklich voice acted, story polished Tutorial.
Und die Leute alle, Alter, ist das ein geiles Game.
Und dann sind sie von der Tutorial-Insel rausgekommen und erstmal durch den Boden gefallen.
Und dann haben die Leute gesagt, nee, ich kündige mein Abo.
Das Game war einfach, die haben quasi ihre komplette Entwicklungszeit, wenn du so viel in die Tutorial-Insel gesteckt und danach gab es nichts.
Das war einfach im Arsch das Game.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Hier, wow, geiles Game.
Oh, ich bin von der Tutorial-Insel runter.
Okay, ich kündige mein Abo wieder und tschüss.
Ja, Warhammer Online, nächster EA Fail.
Von den gleichen, also war ja auch von den Dark Age of Camelot Entwicklern auch in Zusammenarbeit mit EA.
Ursprünglich geplant als 3 Fraktionen, 3er Fraktion oder sogar 4er Fraktion, ich bin mir jetzt gar nicht sicher.
3er oder 4er Fraktion PVP Only Game.
Warhammer Online.
Man muss mal sagen, ich bin kein großer Warhammer-Fan.
Das Einzige, was ich von Warhammer kenne sind ein paar Stories und ein paar Wiki-Einträge.
Wir sagen ein paar Namen aus der Warhammer-Welt, aber das war's.
Von Warhammer nicht großartig Ahnung.
Warhammer Online ist ein Game gewesen, die ursprünglich geplant als 3 oder 4 Fraktionen,
und das kannst du in Warhammer ja auch super machen, 3 oder 4 Fraktionen, oder 3 oder 4 Realm PVP Game war das geplant.
Was auch sinnvolle Weiterentwicklung von Dark Age of Camelot gewesen wäre, weil das hatte 3 Reiche mit PVP.
Und damals hat EA gesagt, nein, wir machen nur 2 Realms, wir machen nur 2 Reiche PVP.
Und die haben das komplette Konzept quasi umgeschmissen und haben gesagt, World of Warcraft ist erfolgreich, wir brauchen jetzt auch PVPVM-Inhalte.
Die mussten quasi ihr komplettes Game-Konzept umschmeißen von einem 3 oder 4er Realm PVP Game zu einem 2-Fraktionen-PVP Game mit aufgesetztem PVM.
Und dementsprechend hat sich das auch gespielt. Das war der nächste MMO-Fail, wo irgendwelche EA-Stonks-Spasten mit geredet haben und meinten, sie wüssten, wie das bessere Game aussieht.
PVM, das ist gegen Monster, gegen KI-Gegner.
Ja, PvE, PvE, PvM ist das gleiche.
PvE, PvM ist das gleiche.
Die Oldschool-Leute sagen PvM.
Das ist genauso, wie die Oldschool-Leute AE statt AOE sagen.
Area hat früher gereicht, man musste nicht Area of Effect rein.
Oldschool-Leute sagen PvM oder PvP.
Das haben die so verkackt und ihr werdet es gleich sehen, das Ding ist...
Warhammer ist jetzt ja auch ein gewisser Name mit schon vielen Fans dahinter gewesen.
Das Game ist durch die Decke gegangen, erst mal initiale Abo-Zahlen und danach ist es sofort wieder abgestürzt.
Guckt euch an, Second Life ist auch wieder abgestürzt.
Das ist hoch durch die Decke und gleich wieder weg.
Guck mal, seht ihr das?
Das war...
So, September 2008.
Das ist in drei Monaten abgeschissen, das Game.
Das ist eigentlich ein
Das ist eines der heftigsten MMO-Fails aller Zeiten, Warhammer Online.
Das ist in drei bis vier Monaten abgeschissen, komplett.
Das haben viele auch noch nicht in der Intensität geschafft.
Das hat sich erstaunlich gut gehalten, das Game.
Ich hab's nie gespielt, ich weiß nur noch im Hinterkopf, dass es dieses Game ist, wo man so engelmäßig rumfliegen kann.
Falls das jemand gespielt hat...
Keine Ahnung von dem Game, so wirklich.
Nie gespielt.
Irgendwann, demnächst kommt auch noch Rift.
Ihr merkt's, ich hab sehr viele MMOs gespielt.
Das meiste mit dem Friseur zusammen.
Demnächst kommt auch noch Rift.
Da wird, glaub ich, sogar ein Video auf YouTube damals so aufgenommen.
Demnächst kommt noch Rift, was sich auch ganz gut gehalten hat, was aber auch durch den Hersteller komplett in den Sand gesetzt wurde.
Und World of Warcraft geht komplett durch die Decke.
Das war die Zeit, wo beim Add-on-Release die Glasscheiben im Media Markt geplatzt sind.
Dort, wo quasi...
Was gibt's denn für Leute, die möglichst weit von Gaming weg sind?
Das war die Zeit, wo Mädels, die BWL studiert hatten, in der Personalabteilung über World of Warcraft geredet haben.
Das war so mainstream quasi damals.
Wie gesagt, an jeder Ecke.
Horde oder Allianz, ich hab nie großartig WoW gespielt.
Ich hab ein bisschen gespielt, ich hab beides gespielt.
Ich hab Zwergheiler gespielt, Allianz auf dem einen Server und auf dem anderen hab ich Schamane gespielt.
Allerdings, ich hab nicht viel.
World of Warcraft ist so eine Sache, die hab ich immer so ein bisschen beobachtet und ab und zu mal ein bisschen gespielt, aber nie richtig...
Ich bin nie richtig drauf eingestiegen.
Dafür hab ich die meisten anderen Sachen dann hier gespielt.
Aber ihr kennt mich, ich bin sowas.
Ich bin ja nicht so jemand, der generell absichtlich das spielt, was nicht mainstream ist.
Ich weiß, ich hab meinen Channel angefangen mit Call of Duty Videos.
Viel mainstreamiger konnte man nicht sein.
Manchmal findet man auch was.
So, weiter.
Ja, Aion hat sich wirklich lange gut gehalten.
Also lange, so 2-3 Jahre.
Und ich weiß nicht, warum das so abgeschissen ist.
Wahrscheinlich, ich vermute mal, weil der Content nicht mehr gestimmt hat.
Das Second Life ist ja immer noch da.
Warhammer ist übrigens direkt wieder vorbei gewesen.
Jetzt müsste demnächst Rift kommen, mal ganz kurz.
Dungeons & Dragons Online wusste ich gar nicht, dass das so früh raus...
Also wir sind ja schon in 2010.
So, irgendwann müsste Rift jetzt noch mal kurz reinploppen.
Das war auch die Zeit...
Die Jahre davor und die Zeit, das war so das, wo jeder MMOs rausgebracht hat.
Wildstar dauert noch ein bisschen.
Das müsste so 2014 gewesen sein, glaube ich.
Das dauert...
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Genau, das war die Zeit, wo jeder MMOs rausgebracht hat.
Wo alles der World of Warcraft Killer war, so nach dem Motto.
Wildstar war gar nicht so scheiße, aber die haben es auch contentmäßig verkackt.
Das war auch die Zeit, wo MMOs ein sehr gehyptes Genre war, die mir an sich ziemlich gut gefallen hat.
Jetzt kommt mal kurz Rift.
Das haben sie aber auch komplett in den Sand gesetzt.
Auch ziemlich guten Ansatz gehabt und dann komplett in den Sand gesetzt.
Man sieht es immer krasser dran, wie es verschissen wurde, wenn Games quasi eine gute Idee haben,
aber die Umsetzung am Ende dann doch nicht gut ist.
Und so war es mit Rift auch.
Rift hat Spaß gemacht, aber letztendlich ist Rift auch die Substanz ausgegangen.
Das sieht man immer ganz gut bei MMOs.
Die kommen raus und machen richtig Spaß, die Leute spielen, schließen 2-3 Monate Abos ab
und dann stellen die Leute fest, fuck, da kommt ja gar nichts mehr.
Verschissen, hui.
Eins muss man ja World of Warcraft glücklich lassen.
Wo hat es wie kein anderes Game geschafft, alle anzusprechen, komplett.
Wie gesagt, von den BWL-Mädels aus der Personalabteilung bis irgendwelche 24-7 No-Sleep-PVP-Leute
und World-First-Clear-Rate-Menschen, alles.
Sogar Craft, alles.
Wo hat irgendwie alles angesprochen.
Es hatte jetzt vielleicht nicht in jedem Bereich so das Beste ever.
Aber Wo war zugänglich für jeden und es hatte einen Grafikstil, der keinen verschreckt hat.
Es lief relativ gut, Warcraft hatte schon eine riesen Fanbase.
Und klar, Everquest mag das komplexere PvM damals oder PvE damals gehabt haben und sonst was.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz hat niemand so eine gute Mischung hinbekommen wie World of Warcraft.
Ah, der Michael 50 Milliarden hat heute sein Vorstellungsgespräch gehabt.
Okay, also was schreibt der denn?
Hey Max, hatte heute ja das Vorstellungsgespräch.
Hat keine 5 Minuten gedauert.
Der hat gefragt, auf welchen Schulen ich war, hab dann so gesagt, ja erst auf der Hauptschule, dann Fachabitur gemacht.
Und dann meinte er, ja gut, wir haben bessere Bewerber.
Ich denke wir werden das...
What?
Was sind das für komische Leute, da hätte ich doch gar nicht einladen müssen.
Hä?
Also ganz ehrlich Michael, das ergibt aus meiner Sicht überhaupt keinen Sinn,
dass die dich überhaupt eingeladen haben.
Weil das sieht man doch direkt am Anfang, dass du Hauptschule gemacht hast, dann Fachabitur.
Dafür gibt es heute Lebenslauf.
Und wenn die das nicht wollen, dann hätten sie das doch sagen können.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz, wir haben uns letztens ja die Website angeguckt
und ich habe mir schon gedacht, dass es Dappen sind.
Predicted.
Ja, ist aber trotzdem blöd.
Aber nach 5 Minuten hast du dich noch gar nicht mal richtig hingesetzt.
Ja, der Chat.
Der war online und er hat einfach aufgelegt.
Okay, online kann ich mir vorstellen wegen Corona-Geschiss.
Ja, Dappen.
Moment, wie hießen die noch mal?
Waren das denen, denen ich das null-png geschickt habe als Bewerbung?
Die müssen wir jetzt noch ein bisschen flamen.
Die waren das.
Ich weiß es noch genau.
Die waren das hier.
Ja.
Das sind die, die keine ordentliche Website bauen können.
Das sind die, die keine ordentliche Website bauen können,
obwohl sie das irgendwie verkaufen wollen, ja.
Erst mal negativ bei Google-Bewertung reindrücken, Alter.
Nee, Michael, aber ich glaube, bei denen willst du eh nicht arbeiten.
Also wer so da reagiert in der Art und Weise, obwohl man das vorher schon wissen konnte, ist fail.
Stimmt, die haben mich nicht gefragt, ob ich Cookies akzeptieren will.
Denn man kann das überhaupt nicht erkennen, ne?
Also, du schreibst ja, du hast dich als fachinformatische Anwendungsentwicklung beworben.
Anhand des Lebenslaufs in Form von, man hat Hauptschule gemacht und dann Fachabitur,
kann man absolut null einschätzen, ob jemand sich eignet als fachinformatische Anwendungsentwicklung.
Also, ich mein, man muss jetzt, okay, man muss jetzt auch mal aus Firmen-Sicht sehen,
vielleicht hat irgendwas nicht gepasst.
Kann ja sein, ja.
Vielleicht hat er sich gedacht, irgendwie, du hörst dich unmotiviert an oder, keine Ahnung,
oder vielleicht mochte er deinen Namen einfach nicht oder so.
Das kann er ja nicht sagen, dann muss er sich irgendwas ausdenken.
Also, vielleicht hat ihn auch irgendwas anderes gestört und es war gar nicht der Grund.
Das mit einfach sagen ist nicht so einfach, Patrick, weil je nachdem, ne, je nachdem, was man sagt,
ist dann gleich mal die Anzeige raus.
Also, wenn jetzt einer sagt so nach dem Motto, ja, sie haben sich hier beworben,
aber wir wollen keine Frauen, dann ist gleich schon mal Anzeige raus.
Also, da kannst du wirklich Probleme bekommen.
Deswegen, so doof es klingt, am besten ist, man hält das vage.
Man sagt dann so was wie, ja, die Chemie zwischen uns stimmt nicht oder irgendwas Blödes, ja.
Aber ansonsten muss man da mittlerweile wirklich sehr vorsichtig sein,
was man sagt, warum man jemand ablehnt.
Er hat einen Pullover an.
Er spricht eigentlich eher für den Laden.
Ja, wenn man sagt, jemand wirkt nicht kompetent, das ist ja was anderes.
Das ist ja nichts, wo du jetzt den Leuten anhand von irgendwie Aussehen, Eigenschaften,
sonst wieder nicht haben willst, ja.
Ich finde es auch blöd, dass man sich da mittlerweile so drumherum drücken muss
und nicht einfach sagen kann, was Sache ist.
Aber gut, ist halt leider so.
Ja, das finde ich auch.
Sleeping Chris, da hast du recht, er schreibt, er findet es ist ein Unding,
das einfach abzubrechen, ja, finde ich auch nicht gut.
Das gehört sich auch nicht, weil man möchte sowohl, also die Firma möchte ordentliche Bewerber haben,
die sich Mühe geben und als Bewerber hat man gerade in der IT-Branche,
wo eh alle händeringend nach Leuten suchen,
sollte man die Form halt einfach da irgendwie wahren, ja.
Der hätte noch 10 Minuten fertig machen können, so die Standardfragen
und hätte dann sagen können, ja, wir gucken jetzt noch,
was wir sonst noch so für Bewerber reinkriegen und dann entscheiden wir uns.
Dann wäre eigentlich alles okay gewesen, hätten sie halt in 2-3 Tagen gesagt,
ok, hat nicht funktioniert.
Das wäre okay gewesen, aber einfach aufzulegen ist schon echt assi.
Den muss gleich eine negative Bewertung noch reindrücken.
Ja, ne, das finde ich auch nicht gut.
Ja, aber anhand von dem Lebenslauf in der Art und Weise kann man das absolut nicht einschätzen,
also Hauptschule gemacht, danach Fachabitur gemacht,
eignet man sich vor fachinformatischer Anwendungsentwicklung,
keine Ahnung, kann man an der Stelle überhaupt nicht sagen.
Woher soll man es denn wissen?
Man muss sich doch erstmal ein bisschen anhören, was die Leute zu sagen haben,
sprich vielleicht haben sie irgendwelche Vorkenntnis in dem Bereich,
wie sieht es mit der Motivation aus, was haben sie vorher schon gemacht in der Richtung,
irgendwas, ja, dass man ein bisschen Gefühl für kriegt, ob das sich eignet oder nicht.
Ich weiß noch, als ich mich beworben habe, damals als fachinformatischer Systemintegration,
bei meinem ersten Arbeitgeber, bei dem Provider, da musste ich einen Einstellungstest machen,
der nicht für Auszubildende war, sondern für Leute, die den festen Job danach kriegen sollen.
Die haben halt nur einen Einstellungstest gehabt.
Und ich habe das dann halt ausgefüllt und gemacht,
und da kamen dann so Fragen drin vor, so wie verlasse ich Wim?
Stand zum Beispiel drin.
Wusste ich damals zufällig, hatte ich Glück gehabt.
Ich habe ja schon ein bisschen Linux-Zeug gemacht davor, ja.
Also ich wusste, wie man Wim verlässt.
Und dann stand noch drin, welche IP-Tables-Tabellen kennen sie?
Oder sind mir auch nur eins, zwei eingefallen von acht oder so, die es gibt.
Aber man muss sagen, ich glaube, die Bewerbung, also diesen Test,
haben die sich danach gar nicht mehr großartig angeguckt.
Wir hatten dann direkt danach noch Gespräch.
Normalerweise bin ich ja nicht so offensiv, was so was angeht.
Bleibt am meisten erst mal selbst und höre mir an, was die anderen sozusagen haben.
Aber ich habe nicht viele Vorstellungsgespräche gemacht.
Also ich hatte von der ganzen Theorie drum herum überhaupt keinen Plan.
Und ich habe mir gedacht, okay, das ist auch so ein Tipp,
den ich immer allen Leuten gerne gebe, wenn es um das Thema geht.
Ich hatte keinen Bock, dass die mich irgendeinen Blödsinn fragen.
Dass die dann anfangen mit, wo sehen sie sich in zehn Jahren, oder irgendeinen Stuss.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, okay, du sagst schon gleich, wenn du reinkommst,
irgendwas zu dieser Prüfung, die du vorhin gemacht hast.
Und das erste, was mir so spontan eingefallen ist, habe ich halt gesagt,
dass die Fragen zu den Cisco-Geräten echt gemein waren, habe ich gesagt.
Da hat man natürlich schon gleich das Gesprächsthema am Start gemacht. Warum?
Ja, ich wusste die Antwort bei der einen Sache.
Allerdings ist das schon fünf Jahre her, dass ich das mitgemacht habe.
Ich bin einfach nicht drauf gekommen. Ich habe da jetzt irgendwas hingeschrien.
Ich habe da jetzt irgendwas hingeschrieben, was garantiert so oder so ähnlich stimmt,
aber nicht wie ich es hingeschrieben habe.
Also ja, so schlecht wäre es gar nicht.
Und im Prinzip hat sich alles weiter von da ergeben.
Wir haben uns ganz gut verstanden irgendwie, das ging sechs, sieben Minuten.
Und am nächsten Tag haben sie mich angerufen und haben gesagt, ja, auf geht's.
Das war das erste so richtige Vorstellungsgespräch, was ich hatte.
Wenn ich jetzt keinen Mist erzähle. Zumindest gab es davor auch nicht viele.
Das war beim Provider, ja. Ups.
Und es hat gleich funktioniert.
Das hat damals echt gut geklappt.
Und das ist echt ein Ding, wo ich mir im Nachhinein denke.
Also, ich glaube, in irgendeinem Bewerb Vorstellungsgespräch Tipps Video
habe ich das nie gehört in der Art und Weise.
Man sollte die vielleicht nicht voll labern, aber ich glaube, es ist nicht verkehrt,
wenn man keine dummen Fragen haben will, wenn man einfach selbst was sagt.
Man sollte jetzt nicht irgendwie das Wort abschneiden nach dem Motto,
wenn der sagt, ja, hier, Herr Max, kommen Sie rein, setzen Sie sich hin.
Dann sollte man nicht gleich sagen, ja, blablabla.
Aber reinkommen, hinsetzen und wenn dann ein Moment der Stille entsteht,
so nach dem Motto, wo man danach dummes Zeug gefragt werden könnte,
weil die überlegen sich ja auch, was kann ich fragen.
Und man sagt halt irgendwas, dann hat es schon den Vorteil,
dass es erstmal mit der Sache losgeht, die man selbst bestimmen kann.
Und die anderen freuen sich auch, weil die sich nichts aus den Fingern sorgen müssen.
Klar, das klappt nicht immer.
Wenn du dann irgendwelche BWL Human Resources Leute am Start hast,
die halt so ein ganz festes Skript haben, nach was sie da irgendwie vorgehen,
denn dann bringt es dir auch nichts im Endeffekt.
Aber bei mir hat es funktioniert. Bei mir hat es funktioniert, ja.
Sleeping Chris sagt, mein Vorstellungsgespräch,
mein Ausbildungsplatz vor drei Jahren hat 45 Minuten gedauert.
Also bei mir hat es...
Also dieser komische Test hat, glaube ich, ungefähr 45 Minuten, eine Stunde gedauert.
Danach hatten wir kurz Pause und dann hat es nochmal irgendwie so 10 Minuten oder so gedauert,
wo ich da drin gesessen habe.
Oder vielleicht auch 15, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau.
Oder kürzer, ich weiß es nicht mehr richtig.
Und zumindest habe ich unwissentlich einen Mitbewerber übelst geschockt.
Da war noch ein anderer Typ da, voll schick im Anzug und alles.
Ich war halt ganz... Ich hatte den Hemd an, ja, den habe ich ja sonst auch nicht oft.
Ich hatte den Hemd an, aber ansonsten ganz normal, schien es an Hemd an.
Und da war halt noch ein Mitbewerber dabei.
Der war so richtig aufgepräzelt.
Mit Anzug, Krawatte und dann noch ein Mäckchen drüber und so.
Da sah wirklich wie aus dem Ei gepällt aus.
Aber der war extrem, der war extrem aufgeregt.
Der hat im Flur gesessen und hat gezittert.
Der war echt fertig mit den Nerven.
Der war komplett durch.
Und als ich dann rausgegangen bin, dann saßen die anderen halt noch da.
Also das war noch ein Mädel saß noch da.
Die hat die Ausbildungsstelle übrigens auch gekriegt, der.
Und ich war halt der Erste, der da rein ist.
So und als ich dann rausgekommen bin, hat er halt gemeint, wie war es denn?
Und ich habe mir wirklich nichts beigedacht.
Ich habe zu ihm gesagt, boah Alter, was die wissen wollen, so nach dem Motto.
In der Richtung muss ich das angehört haben für ihn.
Und da hat er noch mehr angefangen zu zittern danach.
Da war ich schon kurz vor dem Nervenzusammenbruch.
Und danach war er komplett durch.
Das war keine Absicht, das war wirklich keine Absicht.
Das war eigentlich eher so als Witz gemeint.
Wo ich so nach dem Motto, boah Alter, was die wissen wollen, froh, dass sie hinter mir haben.
Man sieht sich, tschüss.
Das war echt nicht böse gemeint.
Im Nachhinein habe ich den glaube ich echt voll geschockt.
Den haben sie bestimmt im Krankenwagen abgeholt danach.
Aber wenn man sich das mal überlegt, mal angenommen, das wäre Absicht gewesen.
Wäre das Big Brain Play gewesen?
Ein Bewerber weniger.
Die haben mich gleich am nächsten Tag morgens angerufen und gesagt, geht los.
Also ich glaube, dass auch jetzt vielleicht nicht die riesen Unternehmen wie irgendwelche Banken und sonst was mit zig Bewerbungsverfahren und zig Firmen dazwischen.
Aber kleine und mittlere Unternehmen, da wo der Chef auch noch selbst im Bewerbungsgespräch sitzt,
ich glaube, da geht das relativ schnell.
Die merken relativ schnell, wer passt und wer nicht passt.
Und dementsprechend fällt dann die Entscheidung auch relativ schnell.
Wie gesagt, bei großen Unternehmen mag das anders sein.
Da muss dann zig Workflows eingehalten werden.
23 BWL-Menschen mal drauf geguckt haben, dann der noch drauf geguckt haben, der.
Und da kommst du gar nicht zur Firma, sondern musst über einen komischen Drittanbieter, der den Bewerbungsprozess macht, dann für den Arsch.
Ja, ich denke, das ist bei vielen so, dass es schnell geht.
Dass man am nächsten Tag, die hören sich alles an und die wissen wahrscheinlich schon, wenn du aus dem Raum rausgehst, dass das ganz gut passen würde.
Naja.
Ja, Sleeping Chris.
Das denke ich, nämlich auch, dass es bei vielen so ist.
Dass sowohl die Bewerber selbst dann, denke ich, mal einen ganz guten Eindruck davon haben, wie es gelaufen ist.
Und halt auch die andere Seite das ähnlich empfunden hat, so nach dem Motto hier, das war jemand, der passt.
Captain Correlation sagt, ich hab noch zwei Tage Probe arbeiten müssen.
Äh, okay, nee, hab ich, das war, gab's da nicht.
Das einzige, was die gemacht haben, ist, ich glaub, die haben uns mal ganz kurz, ähm, so ganz kurz mal irgendwie rumgeführt.
Da muss man dann halt, da muss man nicht wirklich hyper interessiert tun.
Aber man sollte zumindest nicht halbeinschlafen dabei.
Und was ich auch doof finde, hab ich jetzt schon öfters gelesen, hab ich selbst noch keine Erfahrung gemacht,
dass es wohl die ein oder anderen Unternehmen gibt, die quasi mehrere Bewerbungsphasen haben.
So nach dem Motto, am Anfang laden wir mal alles ein und dann filtern wir aus und dann laden wir nochmal ein.
Dass die aber schon bei der ersten, bei der ersten Welle in der ersten Bewerbungsphase quasi einen halben Tag Rundgang durchs Unternehmen machen.
Und das find ich affig.
Das ist einfach nur Selbsthuldigung ohne jeden Sinn und Verstand.
Was hat es für einen Sinn, wenn ich 50 Leute einlade und ich will eigentlich nur maximal, sagen wir mal irgendwie sechs, sieben Leute haben,
warum sollte ich 50 Leute durchs Unternehmen führen?
Das ist einfach nur sinnlose Selbsthuldigung.
Das bringt es doch eigentlich überhaupt nicht.
Das dauert dann teilweise vier, fünf Stunden und es ist komplett Zeit geklaut von den meisten Leuten, die eh nicht weiterkommen als die erste Runde.
Warum, wozu?
Er gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Die sollen ihr komisches Vorauswahlverfahren machen und dann können sie das ja machen.
In der zweiten Runde können sie das ja machen, dann ist es okay.
Da wissen die Leute wenigstens auch, okay, sie sind in der näheren Auswahl drinne.
Und jetzt wäre es vielleicht auch mal interessant zu gucken, wie sieht es denn hier tagtäglich aus.
Aber gleich am Anfang, also ich fand das bescheuert.
Ich hab euch ja erzählt, dass das Arbeitsamt damals gemeint hat.
Wenn man in die Schule geht, da kommt dann irgendwann so ein Arbeitsamtmensch an und sagt, ja, wir können sie beraten.
Da war ich damals mit meiner Mutter beim Arbeitsamt und der Arbeitsamtmann hat halt gesagt, ich soll irgendwas mit Holz lernen.
Ich hab dem gleich gesagt, also dann hat man so einen Test gemacht.
So einen Test, so wofür eignet man sich oder was sind so die Wünsche und so.
Und ich hab halt ganz klar gesagt, willst du euch mit dem Computer machen?
Das hab ich bei allen Fragen angekreuzt, ich hab nix anderes angekreuzt.
Und das hat er dann so belächelt, so nach dem Motto.
So irgendwie, richtiger Spaß, ehrlich gesagt, der Typ.
Richtiger Spaß hoch 10, den kann ich echt nicht ab.
Lucas Crute abonniert Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Excellent Subscription.
So und damals hab ich ja noch gedacht, dass das einen gewissen Wert hätte, was der Typ vom Arbeitsamt erzählt.
TV Hawk, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Excellent Subscription.
Damals hab ich noch gedacht, das hat einen gewissen, gewissen Richtwert, wenn das der Typ vom Arbeitsamt erzählt.
Was ist denn jetzt gerade los, Alter?
Dankeschön für die ganze Sub.
First Neo abonniert Twitch Prime, die Primers sind hier grad excellent am Start.
Dankeschön für die ganzen Subs hier.
Huge.
Jetzt kommt sogar noch der Scam Train an.
Gut, noch was, genau, ich war ja noch ganz fertig mit der Geschichte.
Und bin jetzt stehen geblieben, genau.
Also wie gesagt, richtiger Spaß im Arbeitsamt, der Typ.
Im Nachhinein, aber das war mir damals nicht klar, im Nachhinein hab ich das erst mal kapiert.
Es geht den ganzen Beratern beim Arbeitsamt nicht darum, das Richtige für dich zu finden.
Gerade wenn du noch jung bist, in die Schule gehst und eine Ausbildung machen willst und quasi selber nicht genau weißt, was du machen willst.
Die haben absolut kein Interesse dran, das Richtige zu finden für sich.
Ich glaube, es setzt sich auf zwei Sachen zusammen, was die wollen.
Erstens, es geht ihnen eh am Arsch vorbei, sie wollen ihre Zeit herumbringen.
Ja, so ein bisschen wie Wuppti schreibt.
Und zweitens, das viel Wichtigere ist, die haben ja intern eine gewisse Richtung, welche Stellen besetzt werden müssen.
Also quasi welche Unternehmen möglichst, welche Unternehmen lange offene Stellen haben.
Und die wollen sie besetzen.
So, und wenn wenige Unternehmen offene Stellen haben für IT-Geschichten und ganz viele für Schreiner,
dann versuchen sie, die Leute dazu zu überreden, Schreiner zu werden.
Unabhängig davon, ob das was für den Bewerber ist oder nicht.
Ja, und damals dachte ich halt, dass das so einen gewissen Richtwert irgendwie hat.
Und ich fand, ich muss auch sagen, ich fand mich damals ziemlich von jetzt auf gleich in dieses ganze Thema,
dieses ganze Thema mit Arbeitsplatzsuche und Bewerbung, fand ich mich reingeworfen.
Ziemlich ins kalte Wasser geworfen, weil in der Schule hat man so gut wie nichts in der Richtung gemacht.
Wir haben in der Schule weder geübt, so quasi nach dem Motto, wie schreibt man eine Bewerbung,
wie macht man vielleicht einen ordentlichen Lebenslauf.
Oder vielleicht sogar, wie erkenne ich, ob Unternehmen für mich was taugen oder nicht.
Als hätten wir gar in der Schule mal die Frage angesprochen, welche Berufe sind was für mich.
Das war komplett für'n Arsch. Und von jetzt auf gleich bin ich da mit meiner Mutter damals zum Arbeitsamt gegangen.
Ich mein, guck mal, da war ich grad in der zehnten Klasse, wie alt ist man in der zehnten Klasse?
16? Guck mal, da gehste mit 15 oder 16, du hast keinen plassen Schimmer von der ganzen Welt da drumherum
und dann sitzt dann irgendein Arbeitsamt Spast vor dir, von dem du denkst, der ist irgendwie kompetent und sonst was.
Du hast deine Eltern, in dem Fall meine Mutter mit dabei, die auch keinen Plan hat, wie es heute so ist
und die auch den Scheiß glaubt, den der Arbeitsamtmensch erzählt.
Und dann kriegst du im Prinzip einfach nur Scheiße erzählt.
Zumindest der Typ hat mir halt erzählt, ich soll irgendwas mit Holz machen.
Und ich hab halt in jeder Frage, die der da gestellt hat und in jedem Fragebogen habe ich halt auch angekreuzt,
ich will was IT-mäßiges machen. Ich mein, überlegt euch mal, wo ich 16 war, war das Jahr 2000.
Da war IT gerade richtig krass am boomen. Die haben IT-Leute gesucht, noch unnöcher. Fast so wie heute.
So und aber ich sollte was, man muss sich das mal überlegen, man muss sich das mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen.
2000 oder 99, 2000, also quasi so Höhepunkt, was.NET und sowas angeht.
Also quasi so der erste große IT-Hype, den es gegeben hat in dem Ausmaß.
Und das Arbeitsamt erzählt wirklich jemand in diesem Alter, er soll was mit Holz machen, anstatt in Zukunftstechnologien zu arbeiten.
Das sehen wir doch mal wieder, in was für einem scheiß technologiefeindlichen Boomerland wir eigentlich leben, oder?
Das ist eigentlich unglaublich, wenn ich mir das so im Nachhinein überlege.
Wir haben viel zu wenige Leute für sowas.
Es ist ja nicht so, als sind wir dabei, den Anschluss zu verlieren. Wir haben ja in vielen Sachen den Anschluss schon komplett verloren.
Ja und dann kriegst du so nen Blödsinn erzählt.
So und zumindest, wo wollte ich jetzt bei der ganzen Geschichte, ich hab keine Ahnung mehr, wo ich drauf raus wollte, ehrlich gesagt.
Ach ja, übrigens, ich sag nicht, dass es schlecht ist, wenn man Schreiner wird oder so.
Absolut nicht. Wir haben viel zu wenig gute Handwerker, kommt ja auch noch dabei.
Ich hab's ja hier beim Hausrenovieren und Hausumbauen gesehen.
Das ist ja teilweise Haare sträuben, was da gebastelt wird.
Beim Nachbar die Hauswand haben sie neu gestrichen und unten drunter guckt noch der Verputz von der alten Wand raus.
Also sowas ist halt komplett für Arsch.
Da gibt's schon genug Mist.
Also ich hoffe, dass auch in Zukunft weiter Leute in diesem Bereich was machen.
Das wollte ich damit gar nicht sagen.
Es gibt aber allgemein zu wenig fähige Leute, was das angeht.
Leute, die ein bisschen was können, die nicht total matt im Hirn sind und auch was auf die Reihe kriegen,
haben nicht so viel, in allen Bereichen nicht.
Ich bin ja immer noch Anhänger der Theorie, dass 90% der Leute scheiße in ihrem Beruf sind, den sie ausüben.
Und man muss einfach die 10% finden, die es können.
Ist bei allen Sachen so.
Leider ist es halt so, dass in manchen Berufen das ein bisschen schwerwiegendere Auswirkungen hat als in anderen.
Also wenn ich jetzt Arzt bin und 90% sind scheiße, dann ist das lebensgefährlich.
Wenn ich jetzt, keine Ahnung, Reinigungsfachkraft bin, da ist es vielleicht nicht ganz so wild, wenn ich das nicht kann.
Da sterben zumindest keine Leute bei.
Aber ich bin immer noch der Meinung, 90% der Leute sind in dem Beruf, in dem sie arbeiten, einfach nur kacke.
Und das hat sich bisher so bei fast allem bestätigt, was ich gesehen habe.
Wenn du beispielsweise, wenn man sich einen Arzt sucht, dann muss er erstmal 5 ausprobieren in der Richtung,
bis man einen findet, wo man das Gefühl hat, okay, der hat überhaupt Plan, wovor er spricht.
Zumal ich ja mittlerweile noch glücklicherweise in der glücklichen Lage bin, die Sachen auch noch selbst zu bezahlen.
Also selbst bezahlen zu können, wenn es drauf ankommt.
Und dementsprechend auch bessere Behandlung zu bekommen.
Ich finde schade, dass sowas überhaupt notwendig ist.
Aber der Unterschied zwischen Behandlung, Krankenkasse und Behandlung zu man bezahlt es selbst ist einfach Tag und Nacht dazwischen.
Und auch bei allen anderen Sachen bisher, sei es, wenn du irgendwo was einkaufen gehen willst,
oder sei es, wenn du dich irgendwo beraten lassen willst zu irgendwas.
90% der Leute sind scheiße und haben keinen Plan.
Die meisten sind einfach unfähig.
Das heißt, man kann sich schon mal darauf einsuchen, darauf einstellen, dass man erstmal 10 ausprobieren muss, bis man einen findet,
mit dem man gut klarkommt und der auch was kann.
Ah, die Musik ist übrigens vorbei.
Tja, zumindest.
So, genau, was ich mit der Arbeitsamtgeschichte sagen wollte.
Also, da muss man überhaupt nichts drauf geben.
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, warum ich davon angefangen habe zu erzählen.
Zumindest war das voll für'n Arsch, ja.
Man hat in der Schule absolut nichts dazu gelernt.
Und, ja, ich weiß, es ist 22 Uhr, die 10, 15 Minuten macht es jetzt auch nicht mehr aus.
Und, so von jetzt auf gleich bis du sitzt dann da, total verunsichert.
Die Eltern auch keinen Plan, total neben der Spur.
Ja, und zumindest eine Sache habe ich mir von da gemerkt, dass, wenn man irgendwas mit dem Arbeitsamt zu tun hat,
da eigentlich keiner wirklich Interesse an den einzelnen Leuten hat.
Den geht's unterm Strich nur um irgendwie Statistik.
Die Leute sind in einem Scheiß egal.
Und da hat auch keiner in den Interesse daran, wirklich das zu finden, wenn es um Ausbildungsplätze oder sonst was geht.
Was passt zu demjenigen oder so, das ist vollkommen...
Ja, das juckt hier überhaupt nicht.
Das heißt, da drauf kann man sich schon mal nicht verlassen.
Das heißt, wenn da irgendwie in der Schule einer Zeug erzählt, kann man das ins eine Ohr rein, ins andere Ohr raus.
Und, genau, jetzt weiß ich wieder, warum ich ursprünglich davon angefangen habe.
Und trotzdem, dass der mir erzählte, dass er mir etwas erzählt hat,
ich soll irgendwas mit Holz machen oder sonst was, habe ich trotzdem das gemacht, was ich machen wollte.
Nicht direkt dem Anschluss, ein paar Jahre später.
Ich habe dazwischen auch erst mal Zivildienst gemacht, zum Beispiel.
Und hat wunderbar funktioniert.
Und wir suchen ja auch gerade im technischen Bereich immer mehr Leute, die sich auskennen.
Also, wenn es die Unternehmen nicht auf die Reihe kriegen, die Leute auszubilden,
da muss ich am Endeffekt auch keiner beschweren, wenn es zu wenig Fachkräfte gibt.
Ich meine, wo sollen die denn herkommen?
Also, wenn jetzt alle sagen, wir wollen keine Leute ausbilden, aber wir wollen unbedingt Fachkräfte haben,
dann haben die zwei Varianten entweder doch Leute ausbilden
oder extremst teuer Experten einzukaufen, die es halt schon sind.
Aber ich bin der Ansicht, Leute auszubilden, gerade wenn man ein bisschen größeres ausbildet,
Leute auszubilden, gerade wenn man ein bisschen größeres Unternehmen hat und halt wirklich Leute braucht.
Leute auszubilden mit dem Ziel, sie danach auch zu behalten, lohnt sich.
PC Lustig sagt, wenn die IHK einfach dumme Leute durchlässt, ist das doch auch nicht richtig.
Ja, die müssen eine Abschlussprüfung machen, wie alle anderen auch.
Also, du kannst ja nicht total planlos sein in dem Beruf, wenn die Abschlussprüfung besteht.
Ich meine, die Abschlussprüfung ist wirklich nahezu idiotensicher, ja?
Aber ein bisschen Plan musst du schon haben.
So, jetzt muss ich mal kurz die Fragen angucken, die dazu gekommen sind, habe ich ganz...
Okay, was ist denn das?
Okay, erstmal alles wegmachen, haben wir das, hatten wir ja alles schon hier.
Hä?
Ja, das hat auch schon... Ja, das war der Provider, wo ich dann angefangen habe, meine Ausbildung zu machen.
Aber schon ewig her.
Naja, da geht es schon noch mehr. Es ist jetzt nicht so, als wäre ich jetzt wahnsinnig reich mit dem, was ich bekommen würde, aber es ist schon okay.
Ich kann mich da nicht großartig beschweren, aber mehr geht immer.
Ja, gut, das ist vielleicht... Naja, wobei, je nachdem, wie der Chef drauf ist, vielleicht ist es auch Fußballfan.
Okay, das ist vielleicht nicht das beste Thema für ein Vorstellungsgespräch.
Ja, ach, jetzt weiß ich wieder, genau, jetzt weiß ich wieder, wie ich drauf gekommen bin, Vorstellungsgespräch.
Ich war ja dann, nachdem der Arbeitsamtmensch erzählt hat, ich soll was mit Holz machen, hatte ich mich ja sogar beworben.
Ich war als Mechatroniker oder sowas, war bei irgendeiner Firma hier in der Ecke, und das war halt so eine Firma, die hat uns zwei Stunden rumgeführt.
Wir haben erstmal einen Test machen müssen, dann haben die uns zwei Stunden rumgeführt.
Was hat das mit Holz zu tun? Ja, Handwerk, Zeug, was weiß ich? Nichts, nichts mit Holz.
Aber das haben die damals beim Arbeitsamt quasi gesagt, so nach dem Motto, man könnte sich da mal bewerben, die suchen Leute.
Also wo man genau sieht, was eigentlich das Ziel von den Leuten da ist.
Nämlich Stellenbesetzer, nicht irgendwie, dass sie das Richtige für die Leute finden.
So, und erstmal eine Stunde Test gemacht.
Danach, so einen richtigen G-Bait-Test war das, so ein Test, wo ich heute sagen würde, fickt euch den Test, mach ich nicht.
Das war so ein richtiger Scheißtest im Endeffekt einfach nur.
Kennt ihr, vielleicht kennt ihr den einen oder anderen, das war so ein richtiger G-Bait-Test.
Das ist ein Test, wo sich irgendwelche psychologischen, psychologen Leute ausgedacht haben, so kann man erkennen, wie Leute ticken.
Und zwar war das ein Test mit glaube 20 Aufgaben, die Aufgaben waren alle relativ einfach.
Und so, und die Aufgaben waren halt simpel.
So was nach dem Motto, Rechner aus, was 40 mal 35 ist oder male ein Dreieck aufs Papier oder sowas.
Die Aufgaben waren total simpel, aber oben drüber in dem Test stand, genau, der Krypto-Meister kennst, der Krypto-Meister kennst.
Erste Aufgabe ist alles durchlesen und erst dann anfangen.
Und der Rest sind total einfache Fragen.
Und als letztes kommt dann, als 20. kommt dann so nach, zwischendurch kommt dann auch totaler Blödsinn.
So nach dem Motto, einmal vom Stuhl aufstehen und im Kreis laufen und sowas.
Und am Schluss kommt dann, ok, jetzt unterschreiben und Zettel abgeben.
So, also richtiger Chebat der Test.
Dass man daranhand irgendwas ablesen kann, halte ich für höchst fragwürdig.
Denn es geht entgegen so ziemlich allem, was man die letzten 10 Jahre gelernt hat.
Also, ich weiß nicht, was man mit diesem Test überprüfen möchte.
Es ergibt wirklich aus meiner Sicht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Es sei denn, man möchte testen, wer möglichst hirnlos ist und alles exakt wortwörtlich macht, was der Chef sagt.
Also wortwörtlich, auch wenn das nicht so meint.
So nach dem Motto, wenn der Chef sagt, jetzt mach mal ein bisschen langsam, dass er dann quasi nur noch 15 Minuten zur Kantine braucht anstatt 5.
Das hat der Chef nicht gemeint. Der Chef hat gesagt, man soll es ein bisschen ausführlicher erklären.
Wenn du bei deinem Chef sitzt, blablabla, er versteht es nicht.
Und er sagt zu dir, mach mal langsam, erklär mal.
Oder mach mal langsam, dann meint er mit, du sollst es ihm ordentlich erklären. Nicht, dass du langsamer zur Kantine laufen sollst.
Ja, aber dieser Test testet im Endeffekt, ob du auch langsamer zur Kantine laufen würdest, wenn dein Chef sagt, mach mal langsam.
Also komplett bescheuert der Test.
So, wir mussten erst diesen Test machen. Diesen Chebatetest.
Danach wurden wir 2 Runden rumgeführt. Das war die langweiligste Führung ever.
Wir haben irgendwelche Maschinen gezeigt gekriegt und Leute, die sich geil fanden, als sie die Maschinen bedient haben.
Mag sein, das hat mich auch nicht interessiert, weil eigentlich wollte ich den Beruf eh nicht machen.
Ich bin da nur hingegangen, weil der Arbeitsamt Mensch das empfohlen hat.
Und nach 2 Stunden haben wir noch irgendeinen Test gemacht.
Und das war dann ein normaler Test. So kann man ein bisschen was rechnen, kann man englische Texte lesen, kann man halbwegs Deutsch schreiben.
Also man muss sich mal überlegen, die haben einen Test gemacht, 2 Stunden, die haben quasi ein komplettes Vormittagsprogramm gemacht.
Um dann nachmittags, wenn die Leute schon keinen Bock mehr auf den Scheiß haben, den richtigen Test zu machen.
Also ganz ehrlich, würde das heute einer probieren, würde ich sofort wieder heimgehen.
Das würde ich mir nicht mehr geben.
Aber man hatte damals halt keine Ahnung, absolut keinen Plan davon, hat gedacht, das ist normal.
Ich soll einfach die Leute nicht so sehr verarschen und sagen, was Sache ist.
Was mich auch damals wahnsinnig abgefuckt hat, ist, dass der Arbeitsamt Mann, ihr merkt, ich kann den Typ überhaupt nicht ab.
Also für mich ist das einer der größten Spasten, den ich hier begegnet bin, dass er so auf extrem, wie soll man das sagen,
so auf möchte gern autoritär gemacht hat.
Ja, also, als hätte der mir irgendwas zu sagen gehabt.
Das ist, oder abwerten trifft es ganz gut, das ist so ein random Typ vom Arbeitsamt, der hat mir überhaupt nichts zu sagen damals.
Also ich meine, ich war 15, 16, war mit meiner Mutter da, was geht der, meine Mutter soll mich erzielen und nicht der Arbeitsamt Mann.
Ja, aber wahrscheinlich waren sie der Meinung, man muss das mit gewissem Nachdruck quasi machen,
die machen, sonst vollen die Leute den Vorschlägen nicht.
Zumindest eine Sache, die mich da richtig, richtig angekotzt hat, ist, er hat dann gemeint, ja ich soll mich doch mal da und da bewerben.
Und da habe ich halt gemeint, ja das ist aber nicht das, was ich machen will.
Und das hat ihm halt überhaupt nicht gefallen.
So, und dann meinte sie, ja doch, ich glaube der hat mich dann sogar auf einmal gesiezt damals, so random, so einfach, weil sie ihn angepisst hat irgendwie.
Also doch, machen sie das mal, das ist nicht schlecht, irgendwas hat er dann erzählt.
Und, fuck, wo wollte ich jetzt drauf raus?
Genau, und dann habe ich mir gedacht, okay, dass er Ruhe gibt, sage ich ihm halt, dass ich mich da bewerbe.
Und er sagt, ja okay, wenn wir dann heimkommen, dann schauen wir mal, vielleicht, vielleicht, ja vielleicht machen wir das.
So, und dann hat er sich da dann hochgezogen, dass ich gesagt habe, wir, weil meine Mutter ja dabei war.
Dass ich gesagt habe, wir, nein das müssen Sie machen.
Und ich, also ich glaube, ich wäre damals direkt abgehauen, wenn meine Mutter nicht dabei gewesen wäre.
So ein möchte-gern-wichtig-Tour, Alter.
Stell euch das mal vor, was für ein Vollspass musst du sein, dass du da 15-, 16-jährige Leute vor dir sitzen hast, die wirklich keinen Plan haben, weil sie in der Schule noch nie was in der Richtung haben beigebracht kriegen, gekriegt haben.
Und dann lässt du das so raushängen.
Was wollen die eigentlich bewirken damit?
Wie lange Flamethrower schon in einem Typen, ey, das muss jetzt mal sein.
Nee, aber das war wirklich komplett affig.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das bei euch gelaufen ist, aber das ist komplett useless gewesen.
Da kommt der ganze Hass, ich verschleiere es ja zumindest.
Ist der Baytest normal, also wird das oft gemacht?
Ich glaube mittlerweile ist durchgesickert, dass dieser G-Baytest schwachsinnig ist.
Das ist genau so.
Es gibt immer mal so ein paar Hypes.
Aktuell ist es so das, dass alles super lean, agile und was auch immer es sein muss.
Da wird ein bisschen mit Zeug um sich geschmissen, obwohl die meisten Leute gar nicht wissen, was sich dahinter verbirgt.
Das war mal eine Zeit lang im Trend, dass man versucht hat, irgendwie so ein bisschen psychologisch dahinter zu steigen, wie die Bewerber zu ticken.
Inwieweit man das mit einem Test rausfinden kann, weiß ich nicht.
Es war mal eine Zeit lang auch voll im Trend, dass man Leute nach irgendwelchen Farben gruppiert.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt, aber ich weiß, dass man Leute nach irgendwelchen Farben gruppiert.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt, auch totaler Schwachsinn.
So nach dem Motto, das ist ein blauer Typ, das ist ein roter Typ, das ist ein grüner und ein gelber, glaube ich, gibt es auch komplett haltloser Stumpfsinn.
Vielleicht kennt das der ein oder andere noch.
Das war auch mal im Trend.
Wie hieß das denn?
Da hat irgendein Psychologe oder halber Psychologe, keiner hat da mal ein Buch drüber geschrieben.
Das ist so eingeschlagen, dass quasi die ganzen BWL Leute auf dieser Welt gemeint haben, man kann jetzt Menschen nach Farben klassifizieren.
So nach dem Motto, Leute, die schnell wütend werden, sind rot, Leute, die ordentlich sind, sind blau und sowas in der Richtung.
Das ist totaler, und mittlerweile lachen sich die Leute drüber kaputt.
Es geht nicht um Hautfarbe, es geht um Charakterfarbe quasi.
Also totaler Blödsinn, das war auch mal eine Zeit lang so im Trend, sowas zu machen.
Der aktuelle Trend ist eindeutig überall agil drauf zu schreiben.
Egal was man macht, man kann das unagilste, schwerfälligste Unternehmen aller Zeiten sein, aber wir sind agil, immer.
Jeder, jeder erzählt das heute, alle agil.
Und ganz wichtig, ganz wichtig, natürlich muss man auch schon Erfahrung in Scrum und ITIL gesammelt haben.
Spidey sagt, was nutzt du lieber für Container, wo du extra IPs pro Container brauchst?
MacWheeler oder zum Beispiel Dockernet DHCP?
Das eine hat doch mit dem anderen gar nichts zu tun, oder?
MacWheelern ist irgendwas im Linux Kernel eingebautes, um irgendwelche Netzwerkinterfaces zu bridgeen.
Und Dockernet DHCP ist glaube ich ein extra Interface, wo halt ein DHCP dran lauscht.
Ich glaube das eine hatte mit dem anderen gar nichts großartiges zu tun.
Aber ich kann dir sagen, wie ich das mache, ich mache für das meiste internes Nut,
sei es meine VM oder meinen Container Runtime, das handelt, weil ich auf die meisten Container gar nicht von außen zugreifen will, wenn ich mal kurz was ausprobieren will.
Für alles andere, sei es jetzt hier zum Beispiel für die VM oder für Container, wo ich drauf zugreifen will, mache ich meistens bridge auf die Interfaces und lasse vor meinem Router DHCP vergeben.
Never sub, never donated, genau.
So, ich gucke jetzt mal schnell die Fragen durch und dann gucken wir bridge auf die komplette IP.
Hä?
What? Bridge? Bridge auf ESP33 oder ja, meistens zumindest.
Also wenn das was ist, was von außen erreichbar ist, also von außen erreichbar ist ja eh nichts, aber was auch was anbietet, dann mache ich die Sachen meistens direkt aufs Interface und gut ist.
Die nächste Variante ist, die nächste Variante und das ist auch die, die ich hier auf meinem internen Server verwende, ist mit Reverseproxy davor.
Also da wird nicht direkt aufs Interface gepridged, sondern ich lasse das an diesem internen Docker Bridge null bla Gedöns hängen und lasse auch Docker das Handeln was Ports und Zeug angeht.
Und dann habe ich ein Reverseproxy davor, der von außen erreichbar ist, der dann proxied auf die einzelnen Container dahinter.
Das ist schon einfach, weil der Reverseproxy quasi automatisch checkt welche Container oben sind, welche Container laufen und welcher Port wie gemapped ist.
Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel mache, hier hingehe, komme ich auf meine Nextcloud Instance raus und das geht vorher über ein Reverseproxy.
Und der Reverseproxy kümmert sich um Zertifikate für die Domain und um das Mappen auf den richtigen Container dahinter.
Hier sagt einer, ich habe meine Ausbildung bei der Agentur für Arbeit gemacht, kann das beschädigen.
Oft machen die das auch so, dass sie gerne über bestimmte Jobs sprechen und dann diese öfter empfehlen, ja das wundert mich nicht.
Die wollen halt ihre Statistik, ähm, ausprobieren.
Der Yannick sagt, bei uns in der Schule hat die Frau von der Berufsberatung nichts gebracht und wir haben auch nichts in der Richtung gemacht und beim Arbeitsamt erst mal die Arbeit gemacht.
Ja lass mich raten, die Beratung war auch schlecht.
Das ist gut, sowas ist viel sinnvoller als sich da irgendwie aufs Arbeitsamt zu verlassen oder sowas.
Ich glaube wir haben, wir sind nicht so im Embedded Bereich da aktiv gerade.
Ja dann sei doch froh.
Was irgendein Tipp, bei welchem Unternehmen ich mich für eine Ausbildung als Fachinformatiker Systemintegration bewerben sollte?
Wir haben nur ein Unternehmen im 20 Kilometer Umkreis und das kümmert sich um IT-Lösungen für Bauerlabore und sowas macht mich nicht...
Na ja, was ist das für ein Tipp?
Kannst du das schon so gut einschätzen, ob sich das wirklich nicht interessiert?
Nur weil die IT-Lösungen für Bauerlabore machen, heißt das nicht, dass das was du dann wirklich machst nicht interessant ist.
Also ich meine ich arbeite auch bei einer Bank bzw. wir verkaufen auf Versicherungen und sowas und ich interessiere mich Null für BWL und Null für irgendwelche Versicherungsgeschichten.
Ich hab Keepers.
So, aber ich würde sagen Umkreis von 20 Kilometern, es kommt drauf an wie gut die Anbindung mit öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln bei dir ist.
Oder wie weit du bereit bist morgens mit dem Auto zu fahren.
Also bei mir ist es so, ich wohne ja auch nicht direkt in Frankfurt, ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung wie weit es genau weg ist, ich glaube es sind 40 Kilometer oder so.
Aber ich hab halt den Vorteil, ich wohne fast direkt am Bahnhof und...
Ist das Smash? Ja, ich sag gut, ich sag gut.
Jetzt soll ich Krach machen.
Ich hab halt den Vorteil, ich wohne mehr oder weniger direkt am Bahnhof, das heißt ich steig ein, fahre 25 Minuten mit dem Zug und bin halt direkt da.
Das heißt 20 Kilometer ist halt die Frage, ob es durchaus mehr sein könnte, wenn die Anbindung da an öffentliche Verkehrsmittel gut ist.
Aber wenn es nur das eine Unternehmen bei dir gibt, dann hast du ja gar keine große Ansprache ausmalen, oder?
Was willst du machen?
Oder aber es gibt noch mehr und die sind nicht so offensichtlich zu finden.
Außer eine zweistündliche Busverbindung, ok, das klingt noch ein bisschen weiter außerhalb, dann kann ich dir da leider nichts zu sagen.
Haha, echt, die haben das mit Kabelfarben getestet.
Äh, ne, ne, das ist was ganz anderes.
Also Felix sagt hier, bisschen off-topic, aber du hattest gesagt, dass du deinen Passwortmanager nicht in die Cloud züngst, weil die Encryption in 20 Jahren wahrscheinlich gebrochen wird.
Aber ist das nicht der Fall mit den SSL-Verbindungen, die du zum Anmelden benutzt?
Ne, das ist was komplett unterschiedliches.
Also erstens, der erste Teil ist mehr oder weniger richtig, ich glaube so oder so ähnlich hab ich das gesagt, also das stimmt schon.
Das muss nicht so sein, allerdings sind die Chancen, dass in 10, 15, 20 Jahren ich noch die Accounts verwende, teilweise die da drinne stehen, mit eventuell dem Passwort, das da drinne steht, das kann durchaus sein.
Das heißt, wenn die Verschlüsselung easy zu knacken ist in 15 Jahren und die Cloud vergisst ja nichts, was ich da mal abgeloadet habe, kann das durchaus sein, dass man easy die Passworte auslesen kann, wenn man dann will.
Das ist der Grund, warum ich die Sachen nicht in die Cloud zünge, das ist richtig.
Aber es ist ja was ganz anderes mit SSL-Verbindungen. Meine SSL-Verbindungen, die sind hier und jetzt relevant und nicht in 15, 20 Jahren.
Also wenn ich jetzt Daten übertrage über eine SSL-Verbindung, dann ist das jetzt wichtig, dass es verschlüsselt ist und jetzt keiner lesen kann.
Ich meine klar, theoretisch könnte das jemand aufzeichnen und vielleicht dann in 10 Jahren sich anzeigen lassen, aber dass da was bedeutsames drin ist in 10 Jahren ist schon fragwürdig.
Zumal der erstmal an den Traffic drankommen müsste, was gar nicht so einfach ist.
Unterwegs, ja.
An die Passwort-Datei ranzukommen, wenn du so keine Ahnung, Google, Cloud, sonst wo gesynkt hast und die nötigen Kontakte hast, ist dann wahrscheinlich nicht so das Problem.
Aber die SSL-Verbindungen von heute sind in 10 Jahren relativ uninteressant.
Eine gesunde Portion Verschwörungstheorie oder Paranoia gehört natürlich dazu.
Sonst könnte man den Kram ohne Probleme in die Cloud laden und gut ist.
Also ich schätze die Chancen, dass wenn man eine gute Verschlüsselung, also wenn man, keine Ahnung, man nimmt 256 Bit AES oder sowas und lädt das oder 512 oder was auch immer, eine ordentliche Verschlüsselung und lädt das hoch in die Google Cloud.
Ich halte es für nichts so realistisch, dass das in 20 Jahren wirklich easy jemand knackt.
Aber ein bisschen Paranoia gehört immer dazu und es ist wie bei Explosionen, je weiter man weg ist, umso weniger passiert einem.
Das heißt, wenn ich den Kram erst gar nicht hoch lade, kann mir auch logischerweise nichts passieren.
Das ist genauso wie wenn ich einen Server habe und keine Ports aufhabe.
Da kann mir auch nichts passieren, weil ich nicht angreifbar bin.
Also wenn man manche Sachen einfach nicht macht, hat man auch die Chance oder hat man auch manche Probleme.
Sicher nicht, weil man hat es ja nicht gemacht.
Der Michael sagt noch mal Danke auch noch mal für die aufwunderten Worte, das schlechteren von Unternehmen war den Abend echt süß.
Im Q-Chat, die mit 1 Sternen Kugeln.
Habt ihr echt gemacht? Der Chat, der Chat.
Da muss ich jetzt gucken, habt ihr den wirklich 1 Stern gegeben?
Ich habe nicht dazu aufgerufen, will ich hier noch mal festhalten.
Ich habe nicht dazu aufgerufen, den 1 Stern zu geben.
Chat, ihr seid aber auch böse.
Das gehört sich nicht, Chat.
Der Chat.
Mark, ein User aus dem Chat hat sich da beworben und sie haben ihn nicht genommen und der Chat war der Meinung,
dann muss die Firma Kacke sein, wenn sie ihn nicht nehmen.
Wo ich dem Chat in dem Fall natürlich nur Recht geben kann, weil der Michael 50 Billionen ist ein wahnsinniger Big Brain Subscriber.
Wenn eine Ahnung hat an dir.
Wie gesagt, Keepers.
So, wir gucken, oh fuck, ist schon 2.30 Uhr, ich muss ins Bett.
Wir gucken noch ganz schnell die MMOs der letzten Jahre durch.
Und dann muss ich off.
Also sind wir stehengeblieben, hier alles am abkacken.
Rift leider auch richtig verkackt vom Hersteller, Rift.
Ziemlich gutes Game am Anfang, aber voll selbst niedergemacht.
Sieht man ja.
Dass sich Aion so lange gehalten hat, wusste ich gar nicht.
Ich wusste, es hat eine recht große Anhängerschaft, aber ich glaube, der Hersteller hat es dann auch verkackt nach einer Weile.
Hier Star Wars war glaube ich auch recht beliebt am Anfang, ist auch abgekackt.
RuneScape, guckt euch das mal an, RuneScape ist seit 1999 in den Top 5 immer dabei.
Das soll zu seiner Primetime auch richtig gut gewesen sein, das habe ich nie gespielt.
BDO ist da nicht drinne.
Die haben viele MMOs nicht drinne.
Metin 2 und so ist auch nicht drinne, was mit Sicherheit viele Spieler hat.
Also so ganz 100 pro traue ich der Sache auch nicht.
Rift Wars, da haben wir übrigens mal, ich kann mich da noch dran erinnern.
Hier Rift, da habe ich mit Fabian, zu Rift haben wir mal ein Video aufgenommen, der Friseur ist Rift.
Das Rift hier, guck mal, wir haben damals zu Rift ein MMO, ein Video aufgenommen.
Ich möchte gerne jetzt ums Becken.
Du bist hässlich aus.
Ne, nichts gegen Mr. Schwein, Junge.
So, mal UI einblenden wieder.
So, ja, was spielen wir hier tolles?
Mr. Schwein.
Ja, oh yeah, oh yeah.
Dann gucken wir uns mal deine tolle Sau an.
Mr. Schwein.
Du bist hässlich aus.
Ne, nichts gegen Mr. Schwein, Junge.
So, mal UI einblenden.
Oh Mann.
Alter, Rune Scale, what the fuck?
EVE Online hatten ein bisschen Hype, weil viele Leute, glaube ich, mit EVE Online angefangen haben, weil sie von anderen MMOs enttäuscht waren.
Junge kackt ab, EVE Online geht weiter.
Star Wars müsste noch, Guild Wars, ja klar.
Das geht jetzt erstmal durch die Decke.
Ich finde es, ich finde es auch, dass das Guild Wars, ich habe es mit dem Fabian ja auch ein bisschen gespielt.
Ich finde es auch, dass sie es verdient haben.
Das ist auf der einen Seite gut, casual, zugänglich und auf der anderen Seite hat man auch ordentlich was zu tun.
Final Fantasy XV kommt, äh, XIV?
Kommt, ja, da ist es auch.
Die haben mit dem Lounge verkackt und sind danach auch ziemlich beliebt geworden.
Star Citizen, null.
Elder Scrolls, genau, ja.
Habe ich auch mal kurz gespielt.
Äh, übrigens, die World of Warcraft Zahlen sind komplett fail.
Die veröffentlichen nichts mehr, die veröffentlichen nichts mehr.
Und ich weiß nicht, auf welchen Daten der geht, ehrlich gesagt.
Also, dass das jetzt nur noch nach oben geht, kann nicht sein.
Gerade, gerade zu Legion, zu Ende Legion hatten die, nicht Legion, ähm, ähm, äh, Treanor, Warlords of Treanor, hatten die richtig fetten Einbruch.
Und da haben sie auch gesagt, ähm, machen wir nichts mehr.
Das ist Schwachsinn, das ist Schwachsinn hier.
Das, das glaube ich im Leben nicht.
Zumal ich auch nichts, guck mal, BDO ist dabei.
Was, was ich verdächtig finde, ist, dass fast alle, alle MMOs nur noch hochgehen.
Wildstar war mal kurz auch voll angesagt.
Ist dann wieder gleich abgeraucht.
Wenn es so weiter geht, hat WoW am Ende 80 Millionen oder so.
Ja, das ist Schwachsinn.
Das ist Schwachsinn.
Das stimmt hinten und vorne nicht.
Also, WoW hat, wenn es hochkommt, noch die Hälfte von seiner, von seiner Primetime Abos.
Also, wenn die mal irgendwie 10 Millionen hatten, haben die, wenn es hochkommt, noch 5 Millionen.
Wenn die Accountzahlen veröffentlichten, ist logisch, dass das funktioniert,
weil Accountzahlen gehen immer nach oben.
World of Warcraft Classic war hier noch nicht raus, das kommt jetzt gleich.
Wobei, müsste jetzt eigentlich, kam doch jetzt irgendwann, oder?
2019.
Ich hab den Reddit-Thread dazu gelesen.
Der hat irgendwann 2010 oder 2014 oder so die Datenquelle gewechselt und ab da wurde es kacke.
Destiny, ja.
Seit sie nicht mehr auf Steam sind, lul.
Ach, jetzt kommt WoW Classic, okay.
Ja, nee, die Zahlen jetzt sind totaler Schwachsinn.
Genau, Pre-2014, pretty accurate.
Danach ist Schwachsinn.
Ja.
Ach ja.
Okay Leute, ich muss jetzt echt ins Bett.
Ist spät, länger gestreamt, als ich eigentlich vorhabe.
2020, ich hoffe euch hat das Stream gefallen, wenn es euch gefallen hat.
Könnt ihr mir mal Fallout dalassen, bzw. könnt, wenn ihr wollt, auch mal auf Twitter reingucken.
YouTube lohnt sich ja aktuell leider nicht so.
Gucken, vielleicht kommt da auch demnächst was.
Gibt es irgendjemanden, den man hosten könnte?
Du folgst, wem folge ich denn?
Folge ich irgendjemand, der es gerade brauchen könnte?
Ich sehe gerade keinen.
Die haben alle 2000 Zuschauer oder sonst was.
Schach, ja Schach ist voll angesagt, das stimmt.
Weiß ich auch nicht warum.
Also Leute, wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut.
Bis denn.
Wir sehen uns vielleicht morgen schon.
Tschüss.